Oh good Friday I was debating if I should grab coffee or not but let's just do it raw fuck it let's oh we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna do no caffeine and we're doing it live live I'm so tired oh my god I'm so tired um we're raw dogging this no kaffy do you know that's what the gen z people use that term now that's crazy uh they actually they that's actually what they use that term now they're like they're like we're gonna raw dog this flight by not watching any entertainment whatsoever yeah no i'm for real you know where i learned that from sunny in philadelphia and i was like no that can't be real.
Sunny Philadelphia is always, it's satire.
You're just satiring, right?
And I looked it up.
I looked it up and the Gen Zers, like, claimed the word.
They've reclaimed raw dogging.
It's now a different definition to them, Apparently I gotta stay hip with the kids guys.
I gotta I gotta stay hip with the kids
They've claimed it back
But yeah, there's the new definition for it is basically it but it's basically when you go through something without any other For like you have to sit through stuff with no like with like just nothing I just, yes, got pushed through it.
They got pushed through it with nothing, nothing else to help them.
But that's the new.
So they digged it.
It's all raw.
All right, let's boot up.
Silk song.
Oh, today, I'm sorry for starting late today.
I don't know why.
I never said alarms up.
I've never said alarms up.
I'm sorry, I'm just I'm just eepey I'm playing eepey for 1230 streams because usually I just wake up I just somehow wake up and it's and it's like an hour before streaming and like I'm like that's okay also yes dad did not wake me up because I'm using this new strategy where I just closed the door
It's so innovative, but it's working.
I don't hear him.
It's fucking muffled.
I don't let him in the bed anymore, but all I do is, I know this is a, you guys could try this out too for your dogs or cats.
You guys should really try it out.
It's actually crazy.
You just close the door.
And then you could sleep more.
Oh my God.
Does that blow your mind?
What a fucking crazy concept, revolutionary for our time.
But yes, I didn't wake up.
I didn't wake up from my dad alarm just because I did that because the sparks are like really muffled.
So I sleep through it.
But I was like, you know when you're sleeping and you just keep dreaming and dreaming and dreaming, like that's basically what today's sleep was for me.
And like it was just such a heavy dream that you just don't wake up from it until like, you know, I don't know.
my brain was like, wait a minute, don't you have a stream?
And then like, okay, wake up, wake up.
And then I wake, I was like, holy shit, 1220, uh-uh.
I literally woke up at 1220.
That was how, that was pretty, that was how bad it was.
Um, so, um, I didn't, I, I felt like, like, I don't know how much I slept.
I don't remember what time I went to bed, which is pretty bad if you don't remember what time.
Maybe it was pretty.
I know it wasn't after four.
I know it was Because when I went to bed, I was like, at least it's not at 4 a.m.
Like, that's what I was thinking.
So I know that.
I just don't remember what time I went to bed.
But anyway, let's boot up.
Gog.
Yay, Gog.
Where the fuck is my...
Oh, my gosh.
I will say God's UI is pretty ugly.
I will...
Sorry.
I'm not a fan.
of the ui at all um um sky thank you welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome so thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um that happens more often than you think stuff like scumbag and sucks used to be euphemism for protection wait really yo you a scumbag thank you for the super chat All right,
let's just put it on silk sock.
By the way, I did farm.
I farmed groceries off stream because we're not going to.
I'm not going to make you guys sit through.
Oh, wait, why is my sit through another 30 minutes of me farming the fucking goddamn money in the super Catholicistic world.
We are not doing that.
I did farm I did beat up some some paladins for this so we now have two thousand dollars
We weren't getting any handouts, so I had to beat up some paladins We're not gonna talk to the racist grandpa.
All right, let's go buy some stuff That's right the duchess got bank All right, let's grab the mask We need that.
I know it's not much, but I swear to God, I cannot keep farming.
I was going crazy.
All right.
I don't believe any of these are...
Okay, we'll grab the simple key, because I feel like you guys are going to yell at me to buy that.
So we'll buy the simple key.
Guys, okay.
All right, I'll talk to you one time, Grandpa.
I heard you did some saving for a dear merchant.
there.
I've seen her about.
Sneaking and scrounging, even before he was ringing that bell.
She's a useful sort.
But don't let her age be fooling.
She's still the sharpest mind for a deal.
Won't be long till there's nary a rosary about this shrine, letting it found its way into her pockets.
Okay, that's all you wanted to...
Was that really that important?
You might fake me a dullard, but I this place and have well good sense brought here weren't you from beyond the border of our lands you're correct the one who waits atop like that's literally he was like ahoy ahoy don't talk to him you don't want to talk to that kind i'm like bro that's that's fucked up grandpa he's like listen listen i have very wise words for you ahoy ahoy and i'm like please what do you want to say.
Don't talk to her.
You don't want to be near her kind.
I'm like, okay, grandpa.
Um, he's from a different time.
I seek now to return that welcome and kind.
Beasley words them.
Oh, them.
Who's them, grandpa?
Finally, smoking, smoking, but beasley all the same.
I just pray you don't bring any more unneeded pain down on the heads of these gornless little pilgrims oh my gosh all right guys okay so the city that chose us granted us a little bit where you're living for what purpose so who could say all right so this is a long time ago but do you guys remember that one area um that one area with like like this like intermission area shop where i have to open a door because i don't remember where is it halfway home was it this area that because like i never bought anything there because i was so broke yes there was a random shop with the with her bar fields where the fuck is where is far fields I don't even remember oh yeah it was like pilgrims rest right far fields below graham oh there it is there it is there she is okay we'll just have to do that and then go up here okay I remember now alright we gotta go here there I gotta go back down yeah we never bought anything from that I think we bought one thing from that merchant and i was just i was
just broke so maybe he has more items
all right here i'll go we oh sorry that was the wrong way this is the right way uh far fields
there we go also today i don't know how long of a stream i'm gonna do today because my voice does feel a little tired but i don't know that is it because i just woke up and you'll warm it up more all right we we we okay this yeah it's right here hello whoa oh my god when did when did this place become dangerous all right oh my god every time i have to pay to go into your shop to pay you money like let me out of the i miss hollow night all right okay we needed that all right what is this all right here we need that this too all right good nice Okay,
we got everything we need, right?
Is there anything else that we need to get?
Break the cogwheel above the door?
What, this?
That's right.
Oh, maybe I'm gonna open it and then I break it.
That's right, this is a free economy!
Freedom for all!
Let anyone spend, oh wait, maybe I'll, maybe I've killed them all.
Who knows?
Now, yeah, I think I might have killed them all.
It's like, I break open, it's a zombie apocalypse, and I literally break open the door for the zombies to come in.
Oh well.
Now we'll never know.
You can save, oh well, nothing I can do.
Lack of security and hazard.
Oh, if only I could do something.
I wonder who did that.
I mean, now.
Now he can't lock it up for the rich.
Anyone is welcome now.
Should not have been greedy exactly.
Wait, where?
Is it here?
No, it's down here.
What's done is done.
No regrets.
Shouldn't have charged me money.
And that door would have been what still worked.
Alright.
My little Navigoons.
Where do we go now?
Wait, we should get rid of that.
Alright.
Where do we go now?
I think I spent all my money on everything.
What is this?
I don't even know It's marked on my map These areas Oh
Hey listen The slab Why don't they go to this slab Wait double jump I like double jump Is this double jump area
Hey listen You should make crypto Yeah let me give me a sec guys I have farmed some crypto on the side real quick With this PC left the belt this way yeah
yeah okay all right we got fast travel the slab all right let's go grab double jump let's go yippee oh my god I'm so cold I keep forgetting.
Is there like a charm that makes me not cold?
Like, I don't know.
I'm so cold.
Why did I not wear pads?
Oh, hey, nice.
Child wield.
Hello, Shakira.
Child wielding needle.
How far are wondering takes us?
The cold here.
any blade.
Warm yourself by my lantern while I call.
Barloom is a land of harsh extremes.
Perhaps that is in part why the pilgrims have a culture of testing themselves against it so fervently.
Perhaps when I first encountered them, I had little respect for the weak rag-bungled bugs.
Too cowardly to even carry a weapon, because they're religious!
But Don Daku sometimes rejudged too quickly, and they're all about them until there's no more peace or love.
There is a self-strength to them.
Though it's difficult for me to truly understand it.
Alright, we need to grab the mountain map.
I mean, we don't really need any of these.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, no pants time.
Whoops.
Okay, I need to warm up.
I messed up.
Need to use...
Oh my god, wait.
What happens if I break it?
Oh, who would have thought?
Guys, if you break it, it breaks.
What a unique concept.
How is I supposed to know?
That would happen.
No way.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
How is I supposed to know?
to know guys how there was no warning whatsoever oh this is bad this is so bad I think that was supposed to warm me up oh my god I think I think that flower was supposed to warm me up.
Okay.
Oh, I have to go higher.
Oh, wait.
Do I have a bench?
Where's the bench?
Oh, my God.
There was a bench.
I didn't realize that was a chair.
It's just a rock.
If any rock could just be a bench.
Why can't I just make my own bench?
I'll go this way.
Oh, what the fuck?
I thought she was like, nice.
Then why don't I just bring my own blanket?
Please, can I buy your blanket?
I can make any rock into a chair, apparently.
Because you're not Shakira.
Oh my god, I'm confused.
I hate this.
I hate this area already.
Okay, what's over here?
Oh my god, I can't even, like, wait and see.
Oh, wait, there's another chair.
Oh, wait.
It's not a chair.
It has a chair-shaped!
Sister spider, if seeking commune with a creature atop this mountain, take the climb above us to test a challenge beyond even our setting.
Upon that summit gained, and creature held, no one shall chose what gift to grant, what death as likely as insight.
Is that it?
Oh my god, that is literally just so.
I wish I could just break this item.
JR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is it too late to say happy birthday?
My birthday is exactly 12 months ago.
Anyway, thank you for the infectious laughter and awesome opportunities like Donkey Jam.
26 isn't old, right?
Wait, you're like halfway through the grave right now.
But don't worry, it's not that...
joking guys but happy but late at 12 months a birthday i'm sorry but you don't get a birthday song you that's your little bit just a little oh man if you were one day earlier but for 11 months and 30 days then then you then you would have made it oh it was just unfortunate wait can i do that area?
I don't think I can, right?
I feel like I'm gonna die.
Oh god, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
I sent JK!
It's just...
Oh my god.
This is so cruel.
okay
oh my god where are the lights oh there's the lights okay there's the lights alright where am I and also where am I
alright this way oh nice we actually needed that oh my god we needed that so much
I don't am I I can't make that, right?
That's not, I can't make that, right?
Oh my god, the moment I set one foot out.
The moment I set one foot out.
What's that, what's that disease that you get?
If you're out too long, they have to cut your leg.
Frostbite.
One foot out and I get frostbite.
Cut my leg.
You gotta cut my toes now.
One small move in its frostbite type.
I think...
Am I going the wrong way?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's to my right.
There was something to my right, but I didn't really know what it was.
Oh, wait.
Is that...
No, no.
Oh.
I was like, are you, are you like a little laser pointer?
And then he fucking destroys my entire light source?
I was like, oh yeah, no, not a good guy.
I was like, look, there's a laser pointer.
It's here to lead me, right?
Oh shit, I, guys, I don't know.
I, I, I'm dead.
No!
Oh, no!
It's so far!
I swam so... Why did I swim farther?
Wait.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, that's a little awkward.
I might have to... I might have to eat the thing.
Why did you go?
I don't know.
I don't know why I kept swimming further.
We gotta eat this.
All right, we gotta eat this.
That's a little awkward, guys.
I don't know what came over me.
I was just like, what if I just keep swimming?
What if...
My head was just like, he, he.
Oh my god, I've messed that up.
Maybe the solution is to be further away from...
land what
a unique concept don't you think okay there you go just keep swimming yeah you know when they you know I was just listening to you know when they're like just keep swimming I thought I could just keep swimming did they lie to me am I not supposed to keep swimming oh yeah I'll keep going.
That's not how that works.
And what's the point?
If I can't just keep swimming!
Yeah, there's like this.
Oh, that's just like a little...
Oh, whoop.
A little detour that I decided to take.
There you go.
How was I supposed to know you were supposed to stop swimming?
Okay.
Nobody warned me that.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome to Path of Pain, too.
Wee.
Oh, shit!
What?
Well, at least it gave me a path.
I guess.
I was like, what's that rock doing there?
Alright, nice.
We made it.
How do I...
How do I get that bench, though?
Uh...
How do I get that bench?
Oh, well.
Got money.
What's over here?
Wait, which way do I go?
Wait, down and then right.
Oh.
Oh!
Nice.
Yeah!
Okay, 60.
That means it's a forever chair.
Oh my god.
Yay, my forever chair.
Wait, what's to my left?
Is there anything here?
Okay.
Wait, how do I get that?
Wait, what?
What is over there?
Oh, I need double jump.
Can't believe it.
Paywalled!
I can't believe they would paywall that mask.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we all figured that this is worse than Path of Pain.
Honestly.
I will say this is 100% worse.
Because now I can get frostbite.
I think the fear of frostbite is a lot worse.
Than whatever the fuck Fafapain was.
I did not do.
I was there in spirit.
Oh my god.
mess that up.
Wait, there's a lever?
Where the fuck is the lever?
Oh my God, there was a lever below me.
I was like, it was right below me.
I almost forgot about it.
I came down here for the lever and I forgot about it.
I was just like, ooh, bench.
Yeah.
I just felt so happy about seeing the bench.
I forgot there was another reason why I came down here.
Alright.
Parkour time.
Wait, I gotta warm up.
I don't want them to cut my toes.
Too fair, I have one singular toes.
I feel like it's like I've cut off my entire...
What if I... What if I don't have legs?
What if it's just a long-ass toe?
Oh my god, are you serious?
I fucked it up again.
I don't want to imagine that.
Okay.
No!
Wee!
Alright, I sit down.
Oh!
That's frustrating.
Holy shit, that's so frustrating.
be, like, super precise.
No!
Shit!
Oh, secret to the right is a bench?
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
There was a bench over there all along.
It's that one area.
It's literally that one area.
Oh, no.
It was just some one guy.
Who was it?
Oh, there's a secret right to the bench.
Are you serious?
It's because I accidentally press A.
When I press A, I accidentally press this when I'm trying to...
I feel like I...
It feels like I have double jump right now.
are you I'm just being silly now okay I can't keep I'm holding a it's because I'm holding a I keep accidentally holding a and yeah it's just reflex oh
my god I stopped holding in now I'm too far I'm just being a silly bug.
I need to, like, not hold A, though, whenever I get off the bug.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
Why?
Why can't I do it anymore?
I'm in my own head.
I'm actually in my own head now.
Okay.
Focus up.
It's not that stiff.
Oh my god.
It's...
I'm overthinking now.
I'm actually overthinking.
Okay, lock the fuck in.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I'm locked in.
I'm locked in.
I told Wait, what's over here?
Wait Upward Oh no, right.
Yeah, because I can't reach that bug I'm locked in now
I should have just I don't know, I'm just scared of freezing I'm so scared of freezing Oh my god Oh my god
Are you serious?
Okay, it's fine i'm so scared of freezing let me just let me just like go into that water i gotta you know i gotta face my fears
i keep thinking oh my god i thought that was a rock i could land on because it's just because it's like are you no no i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm Okay, I'm okay.
Because I wanted to let...
Oh.
Oh, I can pogo off the ice?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I wanted to, like, hit that, but it didn't let me hit it.
I was like, what the fuck?
I knew what you are.
I know what you are.
This is, like, the security system that the team...
one wanted to be they they use like pictures of that actual security system to sell their team ones are you serious okay I was gonna be like what do I hit that and then drop me all the way down oh my god are you serious okay
all right apako wait where are the oh no oh no I fucked up Maybe it resets.
No, it does not!
Guys, it does not reset.
Oh my!
Okay, it's fine.
Maybe the silk resets too.
Guys, the silk does not.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It does not feel fine.
I don't feel fine.
oh my god i gotta get over oh thank god thank god for the random bench okay i got it look i'm panicking okay okay if i am climbing mount everest i would not be thinking wow let me go find a bench i'd be thinking wow i want to live i i hope i don't die from frost But I don't want to be the Mount Everest.
You know, like the pinpoint areas.
I don't be one of them.
Like the green shoes guy.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Are you seeing?
Oh my God, it's over.
It's over.
I got to get to my bench.
I don't want to be a landmark, guys.
Jesus
What?
Oh, my thing Didn't regenerate in time That's so frustrating
Are you serious?
Oh my god I don't have enough I don't have enough silk
I need a weave light Okay, yeah, I might as well get it Where the fuck is weaving like okay what do I not need let me get rid of that
okay oh my god I don't trust myself apparently I just don't have death perception anymore when you become a bug you've just lost lose all sense of death oh my I hate this area just give me a boss fight.
I just fight a boss.
Oh my god.
I did so well in the beginning.
I don't know what happened to me.
Okay.
We float.
We float, but not really.
Okay.
Grab the silk.
There we go.
Oh shit.
Okay, that.
I thought I was gonna lose that.
Okay, I need the...
I need the natural light.
God, that shit was so fragile.
Oh my god.
Okay, back to the natural light.
Okay, back to natural light.
Oh my god.
Here we go again.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just use you as a pogo.
Like a mob.
I can't help it!
I'm like a mob!
Tracted to the flame.
Wee.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God.
We did it.
Oh, we did it.
We got dumped.
That has to be double jump.
All right.
I did it.
Okay.
Hello?
What is that?
What do you mean?
Oh, shit!
Okay, when I said give me a boss fight, I meant or.
This or a boss fight.
I didn't mean this and a boss fight.
Fable feathered down.
Laird woman, leap again.
Oh, wait.
Here's double jump.
He's friendly.
That's right.
Wait, what?
Wait, am I freezing?
Am I freezing?
No, I'm not.
Oh, I'm warm now.
Oh, he's friendly.
Nice.
Thank God.
Shit, okay, okay, where do I go now?
Where am I?
Oh, I don't freeze anymore.
That's fucking right I finally put put on pants
That's right I pants now
All right, where am I now?
Okay, there's stuff to my There's stuff to my left I feel that Yeah, there was like a bunch of stuff over here.
Oh, it was just so.
We're no longer pantsless.
My bird buddy gave me a...
Oh, yeah.
My bird buddy gave me pants.
She was like, you are not going out like this anymore.
Put on some clothes, you freak.
And I'm like, but mom!
Like, stop going out so...
I'm half naked.
Put on some goddamn pants.
You freak.
Young lady, you can't...
Oh, wait.
Oops.
You cannot leave the house like this.
I just don't trust this.
I feel like...
There's so many spikes.
Wee.
That's over here.
How do you see...
Whoops.
What?
Oh my god, how do I...
Fuck you.
Oh wait, he does come back, right?
How do I do this?
Oh, can I grip that?
Oh shit!
just get used yeah
oh my god oh my god yeah this is I'm trying to get used to there we go
what the fuck why wait oh it's been so long I forgot I can use that as a pogo so long guys you don't understand i forgot what it was like to be able to jump guys no let me let me through who's here hello a visitor gran you are but you have already a mask already a face is for those without that must carve that's it you're just lord
face a chance to be unto a wither for the faceless I shall provide I can't can't believe it I went through hell and you were just Lord that's that's it take off your mask take off your mask take it off I don't have a charge
attack I'm so sad I'm so sad take off your mask I've worked so hard I deserve to see your face I am entitled to see your fucking face now he's too strong wait wait I know what to do I know what to do boom that's right take it off I don't have I don't have charge attack guys I went through all of that and it was just all I got was lore I'll remember that no he is bullying me for making me go through that pathway it's his fault where
am I now
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, I'm back here.
Did I look at it?
Explore everything?
Oh, we'll never know.
Oh, yeah, I should get the mask.
Now it's my turn to grab the mask.
Let's sit down a little.
All right, now...
Now we do this.
How do we do this?
Oh, is it up here?
Oh, I can just wall right there.
Well, I was wondering, why the fuck was the bug there?
Yay!
More HP.
No, I wasn't blind.
I was like, why did they place this random bug floating there?
Am I supposed to parkour?
Like...
Yeah, now I can take four hits.
I know it looks like a lot of HP, but it's just four hits.
Wait, can this still hurt me?
Oh, shit.
Water's still bad.
Who would have thought?
Water apparently was still bad.
I didn't tank this.
It will just work.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I have a feeling I might not be able to tank this much.
Maybe I gotta stop tanking it.
Oh my god.
Why is it just that much?
Oh!
I thought the light would...
Oh my god, where am I?
Okay, it's not that far.
Okay.
I don't know.
I thought the light would just stop.
I didn't realize it's the world's, like, strong.
flashlight, guys.
I was very unaware.
It was the world's strongest flashlight.
There we go.
Alright, there we go.
I can take four hits.
Okay, I gotta kill this, actually.
I don't trust myself anymore.
I... Wait, what?
It's, like, baked me!
Truly the world's...
Okay, where do I go now?
I guess I'll just go down.
That hurt.
Wee.
Hey, I've been parrying.
I've actually been doing a lot of parrying.
You know what?
No.
Show me where the parry skill is.
I've been doing so much parrying.
I'll prove it.
Sinners.
Top left.
What?
Here?
We don't go there.
We don't.
Alright, never mind.
I take it back.
You know how like Mufasa was like, don't go to the elephant grave that's my elephant graveyard that my my daddy told me not to go there guys that I've been through so much you know you already faced enough of my fears I swam today I swam I swam in the water
this is my elephant graveyard My daddy told me not to go there If the sun does not hit this place I'm not allowed to go
I I have the power Okay, wait, okay I want to get the nail upgrade first How about getting a nail upgrade?
Where's the nail upgrade?
Whispering Vaults That's three, you just gave me three different locations.
You, you gave me three different, this one, Coral Chambers.
Like, please, I need one air.
From, go to Whispering Vault.
From the cog, where the fuck is cog, where core?
Where's cog whatever core?
Where is that?
That's not on my map.
yeah here here here okay guys one one two
green area in the middle yeah neither oh hey god i'm sorry gamers don't look up guys gamers do not look up there we go here we I forgot about this area.
This is where I could get the oil.
Do you know, upgrade?
Not there.
The circle.
There's a circle?
Here.
Wait.
Here?
Which one's this?
Is this a circle right here?
There's a yellow circle.
This one.
Or is it this one?
Oh, here.
Wait, one, two.
That's also a circle.
One, two, two.
You guys could have said I.
That's an I.
That's not.
That's two circles.
Guys, there's two circles.
Guys, that's not a circle.
That's two circles.
That's different.
You gotta call it the donut.
You're right.
That's a donut.
It's a donut!
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh, hey, look.
I'm at the donut.
Look, see, I made it.
I'm there.
Oh, wait.
No, it's above me.
Where's the elevators?
Okay.
I gotta go here.
I gotta approach from the left.
Uh, I guess I gotta go turn.
Oh, wait, no.
Unpack seat above.
You could have set the donut!
That's not on me.
Why didn't you say donut?
I don't think you listen to the chat.
Thank you.
I forgot to swap my charms, but I would live with my mistake.
Oh, there's a chair right here, anyway.
Never mind.
I don't have to live with it.
Oh.
Nice.
very nice okay I go from this side who's talking who's talking right now oh my god forgot about the seam I was too busy trying to figure out who's talking to me oh my god forgot about the seam yet again
I keep forgetting exists.
Oh my god, I don't have that.
I don't have that unlocked.
How do I get there?
I just need you for still.
Go to that donut.
then let but i haven't oh my god i haven't unlocked it though please stop stop oh wait i can go up wait can i yeah
no i can't wait can i yeah i can't there's no up
Okay, I have to go this way.
Yeah, I haven't opened it.
Yeah, I have to go this way.
But I'm here.
Okay, now I go this way.
Wee!
Ah!
I keep forgetting he does that.
There we go.
What the fuck?
You are here, too?
Wait, can I...
Okay, now...
Now I open it.
I mean, it's useless now, but I opened it, guys.
Okay, and through here, I go down.
And then this way...
Oh, never mind.
And then...
But this is where the bench is.
Yeah, I'm gonna go to the bench first.
bench then oh my god i was trying to float down i i swear to god i was trying to float i'm so not used to it wait i can't open this yet how do i open that
see i'm carrying okay not that though but i parried a bit Look at that!
Parried.
God, I'm so not used to...
Okay.
Then from here, I got a parkour.
Oh my god, I tried...
I was trying to...
I was trying to use it as, like, a platform to parkour.
Okay, there's this.
Are you serious?
There was a gear here?
Oh, get out!
I'm Angy.
Yeah, I might have to change.
I think I might change.
I might have to change my crest.
Is what a coward would say!
Oh, shit!
We did it.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm back here.
I'm back here.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, no!
It's okay, we got a shortcut.
We got a shortcut, it's okay.
I need to remember it.
Like, I double jump.
Oh my god, this is so annoying.
It's actually so annoying.
Goodness.
Oh!
Ah!
I don't know how I made it.
I seriously...
Ah!
There you go.
We did it.
That's all that matters.
Let's try to press LB.
That's all.
Yay!
We made it.
A little singing man in the basement.
There's a man that lives in my basement.
get rid of the problem.
It's a boss fight, isn't it?
It was a boss fight, isn't it?
Oh my...
Oh my god, please.
I was not...
I was not ready for a boss fight!
Okay.
Okay, we're a little bit...
a little bit fucked right now.
I was not ready.
I was just like, hey, everyone.
I was, I was, oh my god, you unlocked that area.
I run right into the area.
I was, I just gave up.
Right.
The moment, I, I double jump.
I have double jumped.
jumped yet again.
Okay, let's grab the other shortcut too, while we're at it.
What?
How is this?
Excuse me, I climbed that!
Okay.
There we go.
What is over here?
Alright, we grab the other shortcut.
What's this area?
Wait, I actually don't know what...
What is this area?
I don't know what this area is.
Oh, it's the upper half.
Oh, I see it.
So I don't have to be here, technically.
Oh!
Whoops.
Time to slowly float down to my death.
Whoa!
Alright.
We're gonna...
Oh my god.
I don't know how to get out of here safely.
I actually don't know.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I don't know how to get there safely, guys.
I...
I got a bench.
I'm gonna bench real quick.
I'm gonna use a bench.
Okay.
Now to safely up.
Load down.
Very safe.
Very safe!
I'm trying my best.
It's easier to go up than it is to go down.
Oh wait, no, I did it.
It was easier.
Here we go.
Oh.
Stupid whore Making me do a goddamn arena
There has to be a bench near but Oh my god there isn't Okay Alright that's fine That's fine
There you You're not Fuck you I don't want to deal with you Specifically you I don't want to deal with you
That's fine.
I was using this.
That's right.
Oh shit!
Not right!
That's right!
Okay.
Do I have?
Boomerang!
Oh shit, nope.
There we go.
Twain!
Are you?
Are you serious?
He jumps?
Dear!
Oh my god, he comboed me.
Okay, I actually want to do that just for the silk.
Fuen!
There you go.
Watch this.
Chee!
Chee him!
Chee something!
There we go, that no more singing in the court of Dokilan, chainsaw.
That's fuck you, right?
Give me my oil.
I crave the oil.
It's like, go chainsaw, use chainsaw attack.
I have banned singing.
In the land of Doki Land.
Oh, wait.
That seems like a bad guy.
Chainsaw time.
Oh, my God.
He jumps over my...
That's right.
He jumps over my chainsaw.
That's fucked.
He can just do that.
It was super effective.
He can just jump over it.
Oh my god.
Who would have thought?
Air.
Air type is strong against chainsaw type.
Yeah, I need that.
Who would have thought, guys?
Flying type is so strong.
Secret.
Oh, nice.
Ahoy.
Yeah,
shortcut.
What's the point?
Maybe he's just guarding the secret, I guess.
Ignore.
I...
I didn't think he would...
I wasn't expecting him to just, you know, fly down.
To the left, okay.
To the left, to the left.
Is this way?
I want the oil.
I'll go- I'm going- I'm gunning straight for the oil first.
Oil more important.
Oh, it's you.
I don't know.
I'll just kill him just for the sake of it.
I need money anyway.
Hey.
I thank God he can't jump.
is puzzle no don't say that don't say that there's no puzzles here okay there you go all right it's not like he's gonna come down or anything do i have to keep going left or is he around here
is this the puzzle
oh my god this is the puzzle This is... This is not positive.
Okay.
I can figure this out.
Oh my god, this is my own personal hell, I guess.
That's fine.
Can I bring this one down?
Okay, what can I... What can I push?
Oh my god, there was this area.
Up I go.
That's not it?
Okay.
What else do I do?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, now what?
Now...
Where am I?
Oh, there it is.
Yay!
Just keep smacking.
That's my... That's the plan.
You keep smacking something.
It'll eventually work.
Easy.
Just hit everything.
Alright, now I got the order.
Gotta go straight down.
Yeah, I'll just go straight down.
Fuck it.
I'll get my nail upgrade.
Wee, wee!
That's the jokie way.
You smack it enough, and then you'll get the thing.
Alright, now I marked my map.
No, this is my second upgrade.
Where is Bellheart?
Oh, there it is.
There's so many things on my map.
Ventus, thank you, the super chat, thank you.
I think we're making good progress.
I didn't even do it alright.
We haven't had an actual boss fight yet, but...
But we went through parkour hell again.
Yeah.
I just gotta, like, get used to double jump.
I've been floating for so long that...
I'm not used to it.
Hello, I have oil.
Pinmaster, I've acquired oil with which my needle may see further sharpening.
Bonva, what wonder.
What wish to steal a gift so fine.
Few are the pinmasters of our age that ever worked with such substance.
All right, here's your oil.
Toronto, we shall work.
Now as never.
What joy you grant this humble artisan, traveler.
Let us seek that shine.
They'll last within these lands.
I got the oil.
And now, this pinmaster must work.
Let the sharpening begin.
And more champagne to the Nile.
Stop.
Galil, stop.
Done it is.
Marvel of Farlum, see a glim, your long, fine blade.
Harvest, to the pins of our land, all once held such shine, so much we have lost.
This is fine service, Pin Master, as been long ago since I've seen my needle such.
I had not remembered the finest finesse of its forging.
Well, ye ho, it is certain, yours is blade of finer make than most.
a few that could bear even more sharpening.
Oh my god.
I can, like, slice a tomato with my needle.
If you ever ponder your long road more oil is acquired, seek my surface with haste.
Who knows what form we can find deeper within your weapon's sharpened steel.
Alright, what's the plan?
Oh, I can go for the next oil?
Alright.
Let's make this blade so sharp I can slice air and create a mini-bombing.
Sonic Boom.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we could get Perry now.
You know, fuck it.
I'm going to prove you guys.
I will.
Just like Simba, I shall go to the elephant graveyard.
Don't worry.
My daddy will save me.
Right, guys?
We can do it.
Just like Simba.
Mufasa will come.
and save me, guys, right?
Right?
I'm not going in there alone, right, guys?
This is a spend money person.
Why do I need to spend money?
What are you guys trying to tell me?
I don't understand.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, hey.
There's another merchant?
Long live, the king.
Where's this guy?
I didn't realize we have another merchant.
What the fuck?
Oh, oh, guy, okay, I thought...
I thought that was a real crow.
It's working, guys.
The scarecrow is working.
That freaked me out.
I was like, holy shit, what was he eating?
Guys, that's when you know it's working.
I legitimately thought it was real.
Are you serious?
How the fuck did... How did he get over there?
I got scared.
He was, like, all the way to the right side.
Like, it was all the way over there.
Oh, no, we lost the trail.
Oh, wait, here it is.
Okay, this guy better be flying.
Because I don't know how the fuck he's doing this.
Oh my god, he's sick.
He took me to Sinner's Road.
He actually took me to Sinner's Road.
That fucking madman.
I wasn't even trying to get to Sinner's Road by doing this.
Oh my god, where is he going?
Ha ha roads eventually lead to Sinner Road.
Oh my god, how the fuck?
At least I don't want to be jailed for my crimes.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, fucked up.
Actually, I'm gonna do this again.
I had to do this area again.
Ah, no!
No, my silk!
Oh my god, my silk!
Where did he go?
How did he...
Oh my god, the trail is cold.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I got it.
Hello.
Safely save this, Pell.
But who is this rare care for the shell of another?
Name yourself, good bug.
I am Hornet, Pell.
Your brother wished for your return.
He's not even flying!
How did he do all these moves?
How did you get here?
Where he waits now, I'm sure you'll be eager to see you alive.
Young tip, how he worries always.
Blessed I am for the care.
Him and you, Miss Hornet, a lucky bug is me.
All right, fly.
Show me that you can fly.
It's fast for pill, heart pill.
Bell heart, pill.
These lions are not for traveling with a sharp laden club ah yes to bell her and my brother i shout oh my god you can fly oh my how how does this work you're like bees it shouldn't be possible why didn't my mom bang a bang a fly oh my god and he flew away water water why couldn't my mom bang a fly why did she have to bang a worm how do i get that bench i don't even remember okay i remember now i remember this trauma
i i opened that gate and i knew it was over i knew it was so over that bench was open and i i was ready i was ready to face my fear i
don't have money wait do i i'm zero dollars sorry man you're gonna have a you're gonna have a oh hey it's my reward miss saving we are together at last my brother and myself both return to safety safe i'm pleased you have found one another if you're planning to venture out again i'll urge you to reconsider for the sake of your shell we know it much muchly much We cannot be leaving this home to bells no more.
Here we will remain for shells to survive.
But we instead did plan together clever.
Yes, yes, those pilgrims, them that pass, maybe they will help.
For small reward as we have.
Even you, Miss saving.
Yes, yes, saving is done.
Our wishes now, we ask.
Now it's time for Miss Couriers.
Couriers, I require a raster of meat for an old bug in the citadel.
Can you prepare for me?
A bug up up?
Nays know our finest foods.
If they appreciate, we can prepare it.
Morse prompt.
Miss Corrie has only to ask.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I know what this is.
I shall never speak to you again.
You have never existed.
I can't believe it.
I saved this life and all I get as a reward is a fucking fetch quest.
No, it's not even a fetch quest.
It's an escort mission.
That's so fucked up.
I saved your life and you give me an escort mission?
I have to be your new Ubaite?
That's evil.
That's so evil.
Wait, did I go to... No, it's this way.
I'll turn on the elevator for now.
someone but why does that have to be me why am I that someone I bet he doesn't even tip
okay I need to remember how to do this without the courier to help me I feel like I went like the long way yeah I could have just done that I had to follow this fucking trail and when I could have just done that
I fucked up.
It's okay.
I have the hot ground.
These dogs don't know.
Alright.
Do we save him?
Do we save the prince of Zimbabwe?
Do we save this man?
Guys, he said he promises me like 500 grand if i save him i might as well all right this cost me 500
i heard he's the prince of zimbabwe so i'm freed despite no request of mine for aid hey i received an email that said that you would give me 500 grand if i pay 500 for this key for this amazon gift card
and i do not ask gratitude the key merely fits the lock if you choose stay in here and wait till your shell hardens the crust he needs just a small donation to be freed no i shall depart shortly with my way clear my wish again propels me though i've tried to avoid it Then,
safe journey to our bug.
I'll not pry further.
Clearly you have your own burden.
Is that it?
Where's my money?
That's right!
Where is it?
Oh, you see what I'm doing to this jail cell?
That's gonna be you next.
I'm gonna find you and I'll kill you.
I can't believe it.
The prince of Zimbabwe scanned me.
I'm so sad.
I got scammed.
All right, this way.
All right, how do we fix this stupid fucking bench?
Oh,
hey, money.
All right, we'll fix this later.
First off, we gotta get that money.
Oh my god, it's the parkour of hell, isn't it?
this isn't it it's oh my god it was this all along to fix it i had to do that that's so messed up
oh my oh my i didn't see a spike sorry i did not see the spike oh my god that still hits me i should be legally allowed to cut that i i don't know why I see, oh my god, I'm fucking dead
Tops, I was like, it's over, I can try, I'll hit my head I can't, I can't, I can't help it, I'm too tall, I keep forgetting that there's spikes above me I kept doing it again and again, I was like, surely the fifth time will be different, right?
I was like, I think after the fifth time, my head would have got rid of most of the spikes.
Like a mop to the flame.
It doesn't really matter if I work these guys.
Yeah, I was going to sit.
Eventually, my head would have got rid of all the spikes.
I don't understand.
all right here you go
oh my god I fucked up there
I hate this air oh my god I'm doing it again I did it again I keep doing it again you don't understand it calls to me I'm a maybe my dad was one fourth mom
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
Alright, we did it.
We figured it out.
There we go.
I like how the shortcut back I still have to go through this.
Thank God I have to.
double jump.
Thank fucking guy.
Alright.
Where's the parry?
Where is it?
Tell me.
Now go top left here.
Or here?
One?
Or two?
Shame of YouTubers are just like some punk-ass celebrities.
Sorry, I don't know if that's what Perry is, but like, one or...
Is that where the Perry is?
Wait, left side.
That's actually easier.
Left or right?
Okay, left.
Guys, is this left?
Is this one left?
They're saying that, like, I don't interact.
I feel like I interact so much with my chat.
But it's mostly me being like, where do I go?
Let's see.
That's crazy.
I am the wrong example for that, sir.
I interact, but I don't listen.
Okay, that's true.
No, it's not that I don't listen.
It's that I get one guy.
That's different.
I still listen.
I just don't listen to the right person.
The shame of VTuber-Doki.
I do listen.
Do I listen to the right person?
Hmm, I...
That's a different question.
Oh my god.
Let me out of here!
Let me...
Let me out of here.
My father was right.
Why did I go to the elephant graveyard?
Why did I...
No!
That's...
That's on me.
That's actually on me.
Oh, wait.
There's you.
I was like trying to find the fucking secret door.
Oh, no.
Why did you take me here?
This is the kissing ghost.
I've seen them.
Please, don't suck out my soul.
Toki turned back I did not consent no kisses
Oh my god, where the fuck is that map for this area?
Oh
no, there she is please no kisses I'll give you a handshake, but please No kiss
Oh no, oh no No, she wants the kiss.
Okay, it's fine.
There's no map for this area.
How will I ever know where to go?
Oh, my God, goodbye.
They just want to kiss.
Please, I'm not going to kiss your baby.
Alright.
God, I can't fix my silk problem.
So bad.
I am like...
I'm, like, on my deathbed right now.
It's not the kissing ghost.
Woman's scary.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm still looking at my map.
Wait, now I'm here.
Did I go back?
I went backwards.
I...
I felt like I made so much crazy, crazy...
progress I don't understand welcome back
they not make progress with
the butterflies telling me where to go
I'm dying right now oh my god please I'm playing a song of my people
Where'd it go?
Upright, okay.
Wait, where did they go?
Where did it?
Oh my god, not the ghost.
Oh, there they are.
I shall play you the song of my people.
Where did they
go?
Oh, this way.
Where's the next butterfly?
Oh!
Okay, that's good!
That's good!
They got me away from her.
Okay.
What?
Where am I?
Hello?
what how did i how did i get back it can do that oh my god how was i supposed to know i can't go off screen i went too far left i'm gonna go back to that bench fuck this i fell into the abyss the bench.
Why do I just die here?
Or die closer.
Yeah.
Get me out of here.
I'll go back and down and sit.
I'm tired.
Imagine if I touched that.
I mean, I'm already infected.
It's fine.
There we go.
The bug they're allergic to chair.
Alright.
We do this again.
Oh my god, please.
Please, sir!
Oh my god, I can't.
Because of you, I have to go back to the chair.
I hope you're happy.
I hope you're happy now.
I think I am taking the hard way up.
I don't remember how to get up there.
How do I get up there?
It must be an easier way, right?
Hold left.
Oh, here?
Oh, I didn't even see that.
I didn't realize I existed.
All right.
Knock, knock.
I gotta get Perry.
It's fine.
Oh my god, I almost stepped in it.
Stepped in the goo.
Okay, we got this.
Come on, butterflies.
I play you the song.
Lord Kurosus, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
I play you the song of my people.
Now tell me where to go
Oh, okay Oh, I'll get there
Be inspired
Wait, it's like different.
Oh my god, there she is
Too many women.
It was just so many women.
Where are my butterflies?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, shit!
Where are my butterflies?
Warm and scary.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
Oh no, oh no, please, I have.
Oh no, no, please don't kiss me!
Oh no, no, no, no, please!
Oh my God, no!
No!
I did not consent!
Stop, stop, stop!
Okay.
No, no.
Why is she here?
Okay.
Alright.
Play.
Okay.
They just take me there now.
Thank God.
The women were so scary.
Oh, there's more!
Of course.
Of course there's more.
Butterflies.
There's women.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
I didn't know that was the pointer.
How is that supposed to know?
That was the fucking pointer.
Oh, fuck this.
I'm just gonna die.
Kill me.
I don't want to walk back to the chair.
Okay, there we go.
I just didn't want to walk back to the chair.
It was the only way There was no other solution
But don't you know that was the only way there was no other solution
I ain't using the quick top menu strat It was the only way
Ladies please ladies calm down.
There's enough Doki to go around.
This way.
Can I go from here?
Oh, thank God I can.
I hate you.
A fucking course that'll lead me to the trap i hate these butterflies why why couldn't they make this easier for me why do they need music played every time you're so demanding little butterflies oh my god there she is there she is oh thank god it's next to it
god scared oh there's the butterflies I, I, I'm a little...
You are...
You're mean.
You take enjoyment out of this, don't you?
You little freaks.
You know what you're trying...
You know what you were doing.
You fucking know what you're doing.
You know absolutely what you're trying to do.
That's so messed up.
There you go.
oh my god you're such a whore that's fine i don't need you i found you friends please be inspired
be inspired be inspired oh oh oh oh my god oh my god oh my god
mark out of course you take me from one hell to that oh oh oh oh that's fine i'm okay Too many women.
Too many get away from me.
Dude, there is such a thing as just too many women.
Look, God gave me two hands.
There's not enough hands to go around.
The hair of ghost ladies.
I'm sorry, if only I had four hands, guys.
If only.
But sadly, sadly, I'm very limited.
Too many waifus can sometimes not be good for your life, fool.
I'm so sad.
I'm going to, I'll talk to them.
Please, please.
Please.
Get away.
No!
I have to lead her so far.
Oh my gosh, she's still following me, isn't she?
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't hit a lady.
Oh my god.
I can't.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where did it go?
I swear to God.
Was it up here?
I swear to God if it was not.
Okay, thank God.
I was going to say.
Of course.
Please don't go up.
They went up.
I said one.
I requested one little thing.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, I said, don't go up.
I said, do not go up.
Okay, I can heal at least.
I'm not going that way.
Oh, my, I swear to God, this better be the right way.
Oh, thank God.
They're just watching me.
They know what they're doing.
That's the...
That's right.
Oh, wait.
I should have not freed him.
I should have been, like, stay caged forever.
If I enter here and I get sent back to the maze, I swear to God.
I made it.
No more ghost women.
Thank God.
I am free from the ghost women.
Oh, there's a bench.
Oh, guys.
I was like, there's a bench?
Okay, this must be where the bench is.
Oh, thank God there is.
There actually is.
Um, Yoki, not every ghost woman.
Oh!
Most brutal showers.
I think this was not the right- I think I should have went down.
Upward, down.
Oh?
Our left?
What's down?
Oh, shortcut.
Okay, that's good to know.
like oh what's over here I get the shortcut oh nice I did okay I can get the chair again
all right nice and then we go up up time up time let's grab the silk wait what is there an area here oh a secret I was gonna say, like, where am I?
Where is this area?
Oh.
I went outside.
Oops.
Okay, gotta do that again.
That's my bad.
I was like, whoa, I'm outside.
I missed.
Alright.
Back I go.
I was like, cool, I'm outside now.
Where do I go?
Wait, what?
Oh, um.
Oh, hey.
Oh, ooh.
Nice.
See, my title's not clickbait.
Now where do we go?
This way.
Oh, to the right.
wait no wait where do we go what oh the boss is inside oh that was just a secret secret
i assume it's still right
yeah oh oh more silk we always need more silk
way to open this?
Oh, I wanted a shortcut.
Hello.
Dude, that was a beautiful, beautiful music.
Oh, okay.
Guess not friendly.
That's fine.
That's... Oh, shit!
I'm sorry, I just wanted to say you play really good music!
I'm sorry!
Can I not be an appreciator of music?
Apparently not!
Apparently I can't appreciate music.
anymore in this in this world no fuck you fuck you get chainsaw just get chainsaw that's right that's right I won't even fight you just get get chainsaw
Chase them!
Oh shit!
Okay, I might need to start fighting you.
Just because I need...
I need silk.
I gotta start fighting.
Oh.
Please, I need silk!
Nice, okay.
When?
Oh my god, I don't have any more tools.
I actually have to fight back.
I can't believe it, forcing me to fight back.
Oh shit!
She's so fast!
Holy fuck, she's fast as fuck.
There we go.
Twain!
Like, hitboxes when I land on you, that's not fair!
You're so skinny!
That should do zero damage!
Jesus, what?!
That's illegal!
When?
I could tell, like, her voice actress must be his, like, Japanese voice actress.
Because, like, I don't know.
I know, she's like, I feel like she's saying Japanese to me.
Alright, there was nothing I could do.
That was...
No!
I'm so good!
I got hit.
Oh my...
How much HP does she have?
Holy fuck.
I swear I was doing so much damage.
I felt like I did so much damage there.
I'm so surprised that, like, she still had more.
She still had more.
Oh, what?
Get carried with my chainsaw.
That's right.
Oh my god, she's actually it.
She's actually it.
I'm playing you.
Who would have thought?
Not fuck this, I'm just gonna use that.
That's right, Chaser!
My trusty weapon!
Oh shit.
okay I did not mean to get hit there chainsaw okay I have to hit back I have to have to hit but what if I do one more chainsaw oh my god
no her head thing is so wide the range is so wide it's actually bullshit range is so bullshit oh my god okay I figured it out though my first try was my best try
okay give my chair back I'm not doing this with one less mask oh my god I missed the chair okay it didn't help that her steam thing damaged me I thought that last time i stood in it and i was okay but this time it was like jk it was big
say up more no
all right also that range is actually so bullshit though like what the fuck was that
That was actually bullshit.
That's fucking right.
That's...
Oh, shit.
I did not mean to do that, but that's fine.
That's fine.
I didn't count.
Ha-ha.
Oh, unlucky.
That counted, though.
It's fine.
I had quick here.
That's right!
I had quick here!
Chaser!
Okay, Chaser!
The Siamel here!
Chaser!
Oh my
god!
Oh my god!
Oh thank goodness I did it.
Okay.
Oh thank goodness I did.
I hate this.
I hate
this.
I need to keep hitting her, though.
Okay.
Oh!
I thought she'd jump away!
All right.
That's it.
I'm locking in for real.
I know I said that like three other times, but for real this time.
I'm focusing up.
She pissed off the wrong bug.
For real for real
She She like landed it I dashed her she should not do damage I will say That should not do damage on me Because it's like Like look at her Look at her body Like what the fuck Is she like secretly 800 pounds or some shit How the fuck do I take damage from her It's like standing on me
Like, that's bullshit!
Like, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Arrange for that sometimes.
When?
That's fine.
Alright.
Why are you parrying?
Ha ha ha ha.
stop parrying that's fine when I'll
take that area okay oh I ran out I saw a chainsaw doesn't matter chainsaw all right I don't have chainsaw anymore no more
Unfortunately, I've lost all chainsaw.
Her parry shit is so annoying.
Oh, no, she mad.
No!
She's so mad.
There we go.
Have you thought about not being mad?
I know, it's crazy.
Oh my god, oh my god, she jumped too.
That's fine.
Alright.
Oh, I was scared.
I thought she was gonna parry.
That's fucking right!
Stop!
No!
All I asked was you to stop.
I don't ask for much.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Get out of here!
RB.
That's fucking right.
Parry this.
I finally did it.
Bind silk around the needle and instantly strike back.
Silk skills?
Okay, how do I do this?
Alright.
Wait, I have to parry myself?
I thought if I just press this and it's just...
Wait, I have to parry...
Do you mean I have to parry?
Press a different button?
Oh!
I was like, wow, they opened the hole for me.
Nice.
I have to leave it.
I thought if I just pressed this.
and then it'll give me the it'll give me the thing i didn't realize i have to press a different button so how did i do it i just wait
how how does it work
oh my god i thought it was a i thought oh my god sad I'm I'm so sad I wouldn't I I didn't know the terms and conditions I misunderstood why did I not ask for the details I can't believe it I fought her for no reason you
wouldn't have you don't know that i could have listened i could have all right let's try it out how does work okay let's try this out
oh wait wait i'm gaming wait a minute Let's... Wait a minute.
Ha!
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Am I a gamer?
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
This is good.
This is a good weapon.
Never mind.
I take it all back.
Yeah, I thought it had to time it correctly or some shit.
But it's actually pretty good.
Okay, now where do we go?
Okay, we got all of that.
Get another nail upgrade?
Do you think it's worth it?
Pass the memory locket?
No.
No, don't say that.
I don't want to go back.
Don't take me back to...
No!
No, don't take me back.
Don't do this to me.
Don't do this.
Just climb up and go left.
For what?
Don't take me back to Cinder's Road.
It's just above me?
What?
Oh.
Here.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, thank God.
Don't take me back there.
Don't take me back to the elephant graveyard.
I was lied to.
Mufasa did not come over and save me.
Wait, we need to unlock our crest.
Uh, we'll just do the one request.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to go pee.
I'll be on my back.
You need to watch Hornets sit down.
I'm back.
I have to get more cough drops.
But Doki Bog is back.
Affiliate and Alan Hayes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll figure out.
Is it worth?
Do we progress?
We've been another filler arc again.
We actually stumbled onto another beach episode even though summer is over.
Do we get do we get the nail upgrade or or we progress i don't even know where to progress honestly this we've been through a lot we actually know we're in a prison break arc right now that that was our filler episode we actually got sent to prison and had a whole different arc within an arc where we have to break out of prison nail upgrade all right let's crash out fuck it how do we get the other okay i assume it's this what the fuck oh my god oh my god it's this
all right let's figure this out
i was like hi truly it's not this that's so many stuff and i'm like oh oh oh wait i already filled the journal wait Are you what are you?
Where are you?
Wait I have to Fight a boss to get an ingredient What do you mean?
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
What?
Surely that's not it, right?
Surely that's one That's a one guy, right?
Surely that's That's a one guy, right?
He's one guy to me, right?
Guys, come on, come on.
He's one guy me right now, right?
Right, guys.
Guys, guys, there's no, no, please, no, I can't, please, I cannot go back to the elephant grave, yeah, please, guys, no, you're, you're joking, right, you're all just joking.
I'm so sad, I'm so sad, no, it's, It's too cake.
Okay.
What is the easiest one?
All right.
Which one's the easiest?
In the bargaining phase.
All right.
Mossberry stew.
That has to be in the moss home.
Oh, talk to that moss lady.
Where does she live again?
It's been so long.
know where she lives
top bench oh here that's where she lived okay uh aida aida
the pickle muck maggot is from a boss in cinder road the boss sucks okay we'll leave that for last well we'll leave that for last then oh hi oh whoops
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I should have went to the bone area.
Alright.
It'll be worth it.
This is my long-term investment.
It'll make the entire run so much easier, I think.
I'm not doing plus two.
Not again.
I'm making sure I'm not beating this game with plus two nail damage.
Never again.
Never.
Never again!
Oh yeah.
It's this way.
I've learned from my lesson.
Oh my god, they're so easy to kill now.
Good.
I will get that out of the way.
Hello, I required a suit.
A gourmand of the Citadel.
Would you pass them to me?
A bud who comes through my berry brew.
Strong, they need to taste so sharp.
Here is the flavor so ripe.
Searing, flavor, pleasure, and pain.
They too may see the visions if they taste is strong.
The visions could they see?
Grab the stew for your bug.
To share the vision.
Yes, we shall pass it.
Yay, all right.
Next ingredient.
Which one?
What do we do next?
talk next is in gray mart oh talk to the bartender at the halfway home oh okay that's easy
wait am i broke let's find out i don't know no i'm not i have money i ain't broke get this way get this way there you go I need 480 okay this nectar better be like farmed by a fucking queen bee or something I don't know wait no that's not nectar that's wait where's nectar from the tree that tree better be like 500,000
years old for 480 I better have a 500,000 year old tree from that nectar.
Oh, wait, that's sap.
Uh, Greenmoor.
Like, hold it.
That's half a bread.
You're a bar, not a Michelin star restaurant.
It's like...
Actually, crazy.
I feel like I'm getting robbed right now.
well that flower better be like 500 000 year old flower
well i should talk to i should talk here you have completed your quest recording many creatures of fire bloom in the journal oh my mama look here at the marvelous beasts and bugs all listed so beautifully miss growing up so many creatures now you have cut and thick and smashed their essence linger on you their scent mixing with your own Oh,
ma, you simply must...
No, no touchy.
No touchy.
Back off!
That's right.
The forbidden taste.
No understands, ma.
The sap of such a fierce petted juices will be the vine, but it's not right to do such...
Yes!
gotta ask for consent that's right news wish to see many fine beast though miss grown up you're surely granted and all of news thanks goes to you
that is illegal call me grown up and now I'm a little uncomfortable I need to see your ID news wish it is granted but miss Growing up, we'll continue cutting creatures and adding them to our journal, of course.
I will.
Knowing your creature's form and habits is an advantage.
That can decide the outcome of a battle.
Recording these details is worth the effort.
Oh, yes.
It is very much worth it.
Me hopes you will share your new learnings with her often.
And take a gift to help with your hunting, Miss Growing Up.
Me will add a pocket to your tool punch with a bring of many tools on your hand.
Alright, my thing expanded.
ID I'm uncomfortable now oh wait I forgot I didn't have Adidas that's it oh wait watch this whoa was it made might be a little overkill maybe but I need my money I thought I had Adidas That's fine.
Bontana and Batastacquired Nectar significant age.
Will you chain any such drink?
After the fodder stuff, eh?
Sure.
I might have a few vessels left, but I can't be selling them cheap.
The shells in my cellar the last left in Farlum.
Once they're gone, no bug ever tastes such sweetness again.
Alright, vintage nectar.
There you go.
Hi.
A fair trade.
The age stuffed down the bottom of the cellar.
I'll trust you to collect only the vessel you own.
I'll be grabbing it myself.
It's become a hard... I have to get it myself?
Are you...
Okay, I assume with the $480 fee that I don't have to also grab for it too, but I... Oh my God, this is a boss fight.
This is a fucking boss fight.
Give me a sec.
I bet it's a giant rat.
It's a giant rat, isn't it?
It's a fucking i i can tell i can feel it in my bones i can he i can feel it i this gives me oh it's a giant rat isn't it isn't it guys why are there so many rats down here why are is there so many rats down there oh my god there it is
Sad, Brad.
Oh my god, it's just ants.
Okay, that's fine.
It's just...
Can I just leave?
What if I just leave?
You locked the door.
You...
He locked the door.
He actually locked the door.
That's so fucked up.
actually locked.
What is wrong with you?
Oh my god.
What is wrong with them?
Why would you lock the door?
The bartender is not a good person.
Yeah, yeah, I'm starting to believe that.
Just in a pre-pest case.
I have to pay $480.
I was also free test control, too.
Like this.
There we go.
They're all dead.
Oh.
Guess not.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about this guy.
Guys, this might be a bad idea to...
The bee hit up.
Guys, I might have messed up by being in the corner of that.
Surely he won't jump down, right?
No, he's not.
Thank God.
Okay.
I was a little worried.
Fuck this.
I cannot be bothered.
I cannot be...
Wait, he crawled back down.
Okay, watch.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, I remember how to kill this guy.
There we go.
It's fine.
Boomerang!
There we go.
We did it.
God damn it.
Open up.
the door, Barkeep.
Open up the door.
I just want to talk to you.
I just want to calmly talk to you.
Alright, here's the next day.
I got the wish.
I just want to very calmly talk to you, Mr. Barkeep.
Open the damn door.
So what was that?
What was that?
Oh, you heard a little commotion.
Yeah, very little.
I trust everything went smoothly.
Sir, your seller seems to have an app.
Oh, yeah, just a little app problem.
I assume you sent me that.
It merely slipped your mind to mention.
Oh, yes.
Well, with your weapon and talent and what, I'm sure it didn't pose a problem.
And why, I see you collecting your prize.
So we both came up.
I paid for this.
Trading required means that I get something in return.
Enjoy your next game, Miss.
No simple pilgrim, whatever tastes and draws.
I don't even get to drink it.
I don't even...
Oh my gosh, I could just kill you.
I don't even care.
Oh, and then he...
I have $10 left.
He's like, how about you drink a little more nectar?
Where is the memory locket?
Where is it?
Top left?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I needed this anyway.
Alright.
We gotta unlock another.
Whoops.
I'll just keep unlocking the one-ner-one.
Just in order.
This is like emergency.
Alright.
Wait.
Have I unlocked enough to...
Guys, have I unlocked enough memory locket?
Uh...
To...
To do the upgrade thing?
I don't even know if I'm 9.
I don't know.
Don't know.
Okay, I have this.
I have this.
Oh, wait.
I can't lock one more.
Wait, I have... Whoa.
I didn't even realize.
Wait, alright.
Reaper 1 here.
We'll do it.
We'll do the Reaper 1.
Oh, I need quest.
Let's not lock it.
I don't know if I have.
One, two, three.
Wait, where's the last one?
Oh, whatever.
We don't have to worry about that.
I'm focusing on the nail.
One at a time.
Nail first.
All right.
Where's the next one?
It's a combination of total slots, I believe.
Total slots.
All right.
I can replenish weapons without bench.
So technically...
Unlimit.
No, we don't need that.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Next one, that's not Sinner's Road.
Which one's the easiest?
Which one is the easiest?
Blasted steps.
Okay, but is blasted steps easier than Sinner's?
Sinner is the easiest.
Alright.
I guess I...
I guess I die then.
I thought I would never return to the elephant graveyard.
But I was wrong.
I thought I never had to come back here.
One last ride.
You son of a bitch.
I'm in.
One last ride.
I gotta go back to my prison break arc.
Like prison break when they left prison after prison break to break to break out again.
This is me I thought I was I was so surprised that like, you know after they broke out of prison they the show still continued I was like what more can you do you're out of jail
All right Where do we go?
but where do we go first down okay yeah we're going back in but okay we'll get the bench but here right all right just gotta know
no no no not again no I accidentally read my map instead I saw I just started reading my map.
Go down.
That's fine.
Oh god, that is not fine!
That is not fine!
Wait, how come I...
Oh my god!
Okay.
Hey yo.
I got a barred bracelet.
What the fuck is that?
Yeah, we ain't using that wait that's not it ow wrong way what you how i said is it up there oh i gotta go up oh my god there's the dogs
all right now we explore i guess i
guess that's a shortcut oh
okay here we go where am i Gone, gone, gone.
That's right.
What?
Oh, it's my invulnerability.
There you go.
Actually...
Oh my god, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh
my god, she's using her booty!
That's a big, beautiful bug they warned me about!
Mono, mono!
Holy shit!
She slapped me with her ass!
She's throwing it back!
Okay, I was not expecting...
I was...
To be fair...
I was not expecting her to smack me with her fucking ass.
I don't think anybody expected that.
I don't think no one expected that to happen.
I was not ready.
for a sickness.
Gong, gong!
Send me the BBB!
I paid extra.
You know what?
Yeah, I just went...
There we go.
I paid extra for this.
Big, beautiful bug.
Can I bury her ass?
Wait, let's find out.
Oh wait, okay, let's find out.
Okay, that wasn't her ass, but like...
Oh my god, stupid maggots.
That's it!
I don't think this is a winnable round.
No, this is definitely...
This is definitely not winnable.
Alright.
Can I...
Wait, I can parry your ass?
Alright, let's try.
I want to try that.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to parry that BBB.
Oh, that's good.
I should need these shards.
I can parry everything.
Gun, gun, gun.
That's right.
I want more of that big booty.
Oops, I did not mean...
Are you serious?
I didn't mean to throw that stuff.
That was actually an accident.
Alright, I'm ready.
Send in the booty!
Oh, I guess I wasn't ready.
JK.
Not ready in the end.
Oh my god.
Oh, these guys are so...
Can you, like, reflect that?
Like, if I hit it, is it reflectable?
Barely.
What?
About rid of it.
Jesus, they're so...
So annoying.
Okay, I understand the pattern.
Okay, I did understand the pattern.
I liked it.
Okay, I think...
I'm thinking that I should keep...
Okay, I feel like since I'm going to change crest, I think I'll need it.
I think I'll need it for the...
Actually...
I'm thinking...
I'm thinking I should keep with the hunter.
Or keep with the parry.
I'm gonna do Adidas.
I think Adidas would be better.
Adidas!
Hunter crest is good here.
Is it?
Okay, I'll do it.
I'll keep the Adidas.
I think Adidas would work better.
I didn't need that silk.
I did it anyway.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know you all want me to parry that booty, but it's too much.
Her booty is simply too thick.
It was just not meant to be.
The booty was just so thick, guys.
It was crazy.
There we go.
Okay.
I got a little tooth.
Oh, my God.
I can't help it.
Guys, I can't help it.
It's just...
I can't help it, guys.
You don't understand.
Okay.
It's so...
I can't help it.
It's always the booty.
Too much junk in that truck.
Try pairing it with a strong open hand.
I can't help it.
It's just...
Like, she's asking me to smack it.
And I want to smack it with my face.
You understand, right?
You all understand.
It's so understandable, right?
I understand.
Perfectly understandable.
Like, look.
Can you really blame me?
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god, I'm so unlucky.
I didn't think, like, I didn't realize it can bounce off.
I'm gonna get the maggots off.
Okay, that one.
Oh my god, I can't help it.
I can't help it.
She's...
She's just...
It's so inviting.
Oh, wait, there's more?
What?
What's going on?
What's...
Hello?
Where's she go?
What?
She...
You live here forever now.
I got soft luck.
Are you serious?
She's like, you have been jailed for your crimes.
I didn't know.
She did it first.
She...
She was the one that came at me with her booty.
It's not my fault.
I was the one that didn't consent.
Sir.
I was the one that did.
I swear I didn't consent.
It wasn't her.
It was me
You have been jailed for your sins
Tell that I'm the victim I'm the victim she put her booty to my face Her booty was on my I did not cuz I swear to God.
I did not consent.
Yes, I might have got smashed softer, but that didn't mean I didn't, because that's what they all say.
Please, let me out!
Let me out!
I have the ass bird, freaking.
Please, please, let me talk to HR.
Don't understand.
HR will understand.
I can't believe I have to quit to mend you.
I can't Leave it.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I do this.
Again.
I don't even get silk for it.
I have to farm my silk right now.
Oh, I'll farm some silk real quick.
There we go.
I got scanned.
I can't believe it.
Yes, I may or may not have been smacked in the...
I didn't stop...
I didn't stop her from smacking her booty in my face several times.
But that does not mean I consented to it.
Yes, I know.
Like, yep, it was more than once.
But I was gonna stop her.
I was going to.
You just...
I was about to stop her, okay?
You don't have your stat.
Nice.
Oh.
Gotta make sure.
Okay.
I don't want to, like, stay too close to the corner.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Twent.
I got to have one more, you know?
You don't understand.
I was relapsing.
It's been so long.
Okay.
Now what?
What the fuck?
Okay, I've not seen that move before.
Was that what's supposed to happen if she didn't stop, Locke?
Okay.
I assume that's okay.
Yeah, she just never came back out.
Oh, my God, you're serious.
Wait.
All right.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot she comes back out.
Okay, that boss was a lot.
easier than i expected okay i messed up she was a lot easier i i just got distracted guys i i'm i just got distracted it it was so understandable you you understand right like it was it was just right there it was too distracting you know
the weak yeah like come on we're all weak to the cake Come on.
Can you really blame me?
Alright.
Now's what's next.
It's in the blasted steps.
Okay, where do we go?
What are the blasted steps?
Left, yeah?
I should get rid of all the other stuff.
Oop.
Middle left.
Okay.
yeah yeah
here here
that's not middle left that's top left oh here okay okay here okay now now that's middle left i see it i i see it now Do I have, like, no tram system for that area?
Oh, no, I do.
Okay, I was like, where are all my pins?
Okay, blasted steps.
Okay, I was gonna say, I am concerned that there's no pins on my map.
What happened?
Great boss, clean run.
Guys, what if I just want to look at here the longer?
That's fine.
Wow, wow.
Oh my god, the hyenas.
Eating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, okay, we got over this way.
What item in Sinner's Road?
There's an item in Sinner's Road?
Okay, we need to go to the plastic steps.
There you go.
We don't need it.
It's fine.
Okay, we're all down.
It's on the chair first, just in case.
We...
Oh.
I should stop weeding.
It's like...
Oh my god, okay.
Down here.
Oh my god, you're like, yeah, yeah, it is.
Yeah, you want to get down in my mouth?
It's just like, holy shit, the fuck was that?
God, I forgot you, geometry fuck.
I hate you.
Get down, get down from here.
Oh my god, you're still here.
I will kill you.
Oh my god, that's not ideal.
That might not have been ideal.
Oh yeah, that was not ideal.
Oh, yep.
Yep, I'm not happy.
Okay.
it.
All right.
Two.
Oh, oh, oh.
Simple geometry.
Oh, that makes me so happy.
Oh.
What's that?
He's spitting on me too.
It's like, ha, whoa.
That's crazy.
She did that crypto scam and never came back.
She actually rug pulled successfully.
She went, oh!
Oh my god, thank god I quit mine.
I don't know if this actually will work, but oh my god, I actually landed on that.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, there's too many things on my screen.
I hate it.
There's way too many things on my screen right now.
I don't feel fine, but it's fine.
I know I can dodge that.
Nice.
One down.
That's right.
I killed your lover.
I hope you die alone now.
That's right.
What?
The love of your life is dead.
I hope you live a long life and die alone knowing I killed your love of your life.
Oh, that's it?
So long as you can prove the triangle is indeed a triangle, geometry is a...
Okay, thank you for the super chat eating.
Thank you, thank you.
That's fucking right.
I found the Apotenuse.
Alright.
I still have to keep going?
There's no way he's gonna swore revenge on me, right?
Nah, surely he ain't gonna swore revenge for me killing the love of his life.
No way.
I can't see.
they could never oh hey nice a chair hello are you alive so rude to raise a pen stress from their deep meditation you carry on with that kind of rash behavior and you're likely to be struck quick through
i'm surprised to find them well it goes sound mine alive in such a in hospital place you're a Warrior learned in the blades of this land?
Hi, a pinstress.
Your kneel there might fit you fair.
Strange as it is and all, but it's a pin that the glorious weapon of Farloon.
Given I'm not awake, maybe you fancy a little training.
Care to test the power of pinstress?
Might be even this old master could show you a thing or two.
Sure.
For free?
Oh my god, you're not gonna monetize this, like all the other fucking bugs?
Well, choice, you know, bug.
Let's get our shells are shaken.
Thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Someone that's willing to teach me for free.
I didn't know how good I had it in Hollow Knight.
The first free thing in ages.
How grand.
To face an opponent with a bit of energy.
Your skill won clear enough.
I hope my training has granted some insight.
Yeah, I don't know if I'll ever use this.
All right, where do we go now?
I assume it's this thing.
Oh, left.
Whoops.
Yes, it was in that thing.
Okay, I...
Not here.
This way.
I'll just hang here a little bit Because I'm scared Just hang in there
Okay now I go this way
Alright That must be it This must be where I have to go
And I saw this guy And I was like, fuck, I...
Oh, I hate you.
Get out of here.
Oh, my God.
Of course.
Of course there's a rock.
Oh, my God.
I have to do this parkour thing all over again, too.
Later.
I can feel it.
Was I supposed to destroy that?
Oh.
Crow sways, clear water flows.
Upon our river, free of time.
I was like, fuck reading!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm just gonna farm this for silk, actually.
Oh!
Oops.
Look, I did not expect that platform.
Oh, I am really...
hanging by the thread right now.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my!
Oh, fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
Oh, my God.
You know what?
I...
No!
I hate this place.
I'm just gonna hang in there.
He's gonna hang in there.
I didn't think.
I didn't.
I forgot about this fucker.
I was like, whoa, cool speedrun.
Take that shit.
And I forgot.
I left him alive.
I forgot.
I left that fucker alive.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna kill him before he fucks me up again.
Oh my god.
Why are you going down?
down you're such a fucker come back down here come oh my god he's such a little shit he actually is oh now you come down okay he's such a little shit he knows what he's doing too all right
Yeah, he was taunting me.
Okay, I don't...
Actually...
No, I don't need to farm it.
I need to do this again.
Okay.
There we go.
I didn't need to grab my silk.
Okay.
How?
What's...
I forgot that was also a timed area.
I forgot that was also timed.
I'm so stupid.
I thought it was the other platform I thought it was this area
Speedrun It was planned It was simply planned
I thought that was a safe zone I was like I'm ready But it was still worms It was still worms.
Who would have thought?
It's always just worms.
Oh, wait.
Is she here?
Oh, hello, hello.
Oh, hello.
They're greeting, Shakira.
In these drifts consumed by Krustin's sand, those cabins have returned to nature by seeing evidence of bold structures buried throughout.
The shows of their bolder right builders rest in a tower above a grand tribe they seem and strong fighters i'm sure alas they exist now only as hard and husk lamb a child wielding needle we live too late to match their claws i'm broke i'm they didn't carry any cash on them okay that's fine i don't need cash i'm i'm okay i didn't realize that I did not realize that these fuckers live in a cashless society.
Who would have thought?
They live.
Oh, wait, I was...
Oh, my God.
You're right.
I have a rosary.
I'm coming back down.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
I forgot the most important part using the rosary.
Don't worry, I got the money.
Oh, give me a sec.
I got it.
All right, now I got it.
Oh, there's a bench?
Where?
What?
What's this area?
Yeah?
All the way down?
Oh, to the right.
Oh, I thought you meant the shortcut.
This way.
Oh, do not go right.
Alright, now I'm here.
Have I used that bench already?
Wait, guys, have I already...
I've already done that bench, right?
I don't remember.
Have I?
I already sat there.
Oh, at the pinst...
Oh, wait, I rested at her.
I forgot about her already.
She was...
She was not that important in my life, apparently.
Because I already forgot she existed.
What's over here again?
Wait, what the fuck is in my pocket?
Oh, what's up?
Pickled whatever shit.
What's over here?
Hello?
Oh my god, it's you.
Oh, hey then.
Fancy, fancy bug, like you keep being cringe Those cozy little nook where?
Here we got some nice stuff, did you?
Oh, oh, oh, all kinds of tasty goodies Find their way here, that's for sure.
I care very, very little How you procure your goods, thief.
Do you have something worth trading?
I'm in part with my rosary.
Well, we never say no to a fair trade.
Now take a look at what we got.
All right, this does not seem fair.
This absolutely does not seem fair.
Oh, this is for better farming.
Might think of, like, give the chip.
Thank you.
Alright, there's the Nino stuff.
Oh, alright.
Can you even get this?
You stole these.
I wish I stole them first.
It's not fair.
It should have been me to steal it first.
Alright.
I should steal it.
Back, you're right.
I should steal it back from him.
Alright, now I gotta figure out it.
I gotta go all the way back.
A bako.
I mean, it's not that bad.
Yeah, it feels like a shortcut.
Thank God.
It's like a shortcut or something.
Is that crazy?
That felt like a shortcut.
Okay, these guys are not annoying.
Yeah, it's definitely easier than running from the Pinterest place.
Wait, what?
Where do I go from here?
Push left wall.
This one?
Spikes down left.
Oh, this one!
Okay.
Hello, I'm here.
I am here to ruin your home.
That's right.
Fight amongst yourself.
Fight.
God, I hate you.
I hope my nail upgrade kills you a little faster.
Oh, my!
Fuck you!
Bottom right.
Oh, my God.
that's fine that's fine I I just wanted to touch it I guess
but I'm like actually it's so risky what I'm doing the spikes they call for me oh Oh!
Oh my god, please give me enough.
Thank God.
Surely nothing will go wrong, right?
It's the- it's the double!
I swear to God!
I swear to God, it's the double jump!
I swear!
I- Badoki, you're not- No, it's- it's the double jump.
I swear It's the double jump It's the only way I can explain it
Sure, dokey
No, I'm scared I got scared I got scared of the spikes They were right above me
It's okay.
That's fine.
I have learned.
Alright.
Abaco.
I missed these guys.
Why can't it be these guys as my enemies?
Okay.
Oh my god.
His body.
His body just smacked me.
That should be illegal.
Ref!
Oh my god, there it is.
Okay, I gotta get released.
I don't wanna hit my head.
I- I can't- no!
I can't open!
You don't understand!
No!
It calls for me!
Those spikes!
It keeps calling!
I don't even know where I'm supposed to be at.
Yeah.
I'll get these out so I don't hit my head.
I have to.
Safety first.
Whoa.
Okay, nice.
Safety first.
There you go.
What a little...
Nice surprise.
Wait, how do I leave?
How do I leave?
Okay.
Now go back.
Wait, but what's over here then?
Oh, absolute death.
That's cool.
Oh, nothing.
I love it when you get absolutely nothing.
Yay!
Tihi.
Oh my god, not you.
Watch you again.
Get me out of here.
Okay, uh, bench.
Oh, I missed something?
What did I miss?
No, I don't believe you.
I don't believe you.
There.
Okay.
Let's slowly float down.
all right all
right now is the act okay what do you mean now is the okay now where do we go last ingredient here
oh bell wait what's here then down left burst what's down left okay bell heart what's over here
an item okay but am I actually gonna use this item the fuck is this
what does it do
he's dead what is he supposed to be alive what what's wrong yeah Like, it was like, he's dead!
It's, please, don't you want to...
You're supposed to gamble.
Goodbye.
Apparently you would have gambled with me.
We did it.
We beat our gambling addiction.
We did it, guys.
He gambled his last gambler.
Oh, and a chance to nullify.
Oh, I should put that.
Oh, that's good.
That's crazy.
We're freed.
I never got addicted to gambling, guys.
We did it.
We don't have to go to rehab.
Just wait until the guy dies.
Just wait.
Wait until your dealer dies.
We don't need to go to rehab.
all right I'm gonna grab water I'll hear back
all right I got my water gotta blow my nose all
right let's go we gotta go where do we have to go okay bell heart we gotta go to bell heart I had to do the worst one now get the worst oh it was just next to me.
New water.
New water bottle is just next to me.
I just have to get out of my room.
Alright.
Where do we go?
We're in Belhite.
No, I need my compass.
You guys don't understand.
I'm so...
You don't understand.
I need the compass.
The courier is rashing.
This guy?
Hey.
No talking.
Yeah.
As it is yours, Miss Courier.
Meats prepare fresh as fresh in our special way.
Miss Courier must know our rash is delicious, strong, fatty food, but it's not long and less.
If not story quick, it is flavor-feeding faster and foul.
If the rash is likely to spoil, I shall make fastest in the dough.
I'm most desired to see your efforts or your scant supplies wasted.
Behold, before the poor art, you must know.
All the lawyers are in need of great, great care.
No bumps, no shake, no taking, funny traffic sport.
A lace claw wing must be used.
Oh, it's...
Oh, my God.
I'm going to fast travel.
I need the flee thing.
Oh, it is time?
Alright, that's it.
I'm using the fast travel.
I need to grab the flea juice We're gonna Oh you don't need it Okay I was gonna break it I was gonna break it Yeah I know I know it was I know it breaks the thing I was planning on breaking it Holy shit How do I do I get there?
Okay.
Let me figure this out.
Blasted steps and then oh my god.
Wait, where am I?
First off, where am I?
Do I need to be faster though?
Like, does that actually would that actually help me?
Okay, we need the compass.
We don't need that then.
Okay.
Doki is time.
Give me a sec.
I need to figure this out.
Guys, I need to look at that map.
How do I get over there?
Okay, left, up.
Left, up.
And
then...
one of them is not real.
Oh, there he is.
Guys, I don't think I'm going to make it.
I already have zero hopes in us.
Yeah, we're not making it.
Wait, what?
Where do I go now?
Up, up, right.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Okay.
Wait, how do I get up?
Oh my god, there's no up.
there's no up there's no up there's there's no up i thought there was an up
oh my god to keep looking i i legitimately don't remember how to play how to how to go around here
i'm so confused where am i oh
no i fucked up this is a practice run this is a run where i'm trying to figure out where i am Where am I?
This is the eternal.
Where am I, run?
It's over.
I forgot he existed.
Alright.
It's fine.
This is already over.
I gotta unlock the shortcut.
Where is that shortcut?
Okay.
Apparently there is a shortcut.
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
Where is this?
If this is a shortcut, then how do I...
Alright.
Okay, it's time to fall back down.
It's time we fall back down.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
we go back it's just we're just learning the route guys
all right what a phantom i am don't make me go back to the kissing ghost don't
there you go please please i don't want to go back no there's no more kissing okay we'll unlock that then pathway?
Like how?
Okay, how do we get there?
He's like here?
How do we get there?
Oh!
Here!
Alright.
Wait, that path is harder?
It's time to find out.
Alright.
try it we gotta go back to the elephant graveyard yet again I
just realized I have not eaten lunch yet I should get something to eat I should really get something to eat oh hey oh nice I shouldn't even refill this too yes please oh we gotta go this way.
Can I swim?
Okay, I can.
Wait, actually, how do I do this?
Up.
Right.
Okay.
Alright, after we get to Sinner's Road, we'll grab something to eat.
And then here?
Okay.
Ah!
It's over.
Get me out of here.
We go back.
It's already over.
I forgot you.
Just killed me.
It's been so long!
And it's over.
Oh!
Hello!
Alright.
I'm I'm gonna heat something up.
I'll be back.
I'm hungry
Back I got my food I have a breakfast sandwich even though it's not breakfast anymore it might be like almost dinner time uh many thank you super chat thank you thank you society i think you're the gift of shows thank you thank you there's one of my pre-cooked meals i want my my breakfast sandwich
it has egg bacon and pesto oh my gosh so hot oh my gosh i just microwaved it No food break for everybody Everyone grab a snack And drink Before we go through hell yet again
Yeah it's a dinner at me Oh dad's coming over He knows There he is He's like you're eating without me bitch
And he smells your bacon.
He's very food motivated.
I swear.
He is a dog where if he wasn't domesticated, I think his parents will leave him at birth.
He's so lucky.
He was born in the right time.
You know how people would be like, man, I was born in the wrong era.
He is so lucky.
He was 100% born in the right time at the right place.
Don't say that about him.
We all know.
He's a genetic mess, and we all know I love him.
I love him even though he's a genetic freak.
This is my entertainment.
This lady dancing.
He's a genetic freak, but he's my genetic freak.
I'm joking it's sir dad now Hey no no No you're not getting my breakfast I haven't you've eaten dinner You've sorry you've eaten lunch I haven't
I didn't eat yet.
Look at his fat belly.
He's gonna starve.
He even got a tree.
I wish I could kill that, bud.
I don't know.
this is not this is like free entertainment but i can't turn it off
all right i'm gonna wash my hands and then when they were ready i finish eating my sandwich
i'm ready wash my hands all right i know the route now
oh wait i still have it oh shit okay that's awkward i thought i thought it expired but i guess where i sat on the chair, it doesn't expire.
It's alright.
I'll just break it.
Don't worry.
Boom!
It's time to break the meat.
But I can just bump into the walls.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Okay, now that I know that, bumping into walls also breaks it.
I gotta be careful then.
I didn't realize you can actually bump into the walls.
God, I'd rather just...
I'd rather really just fight a boss.
Like, I...
Oh, wait.
I should equip the fast thing, right?
There we go.
Oh.
Why am I poisoned?
Wait, I'm poisoned now, too?
Am I fast?
Oh, babe, thank you for the...
If I get the ships, thank you, thank you.
Wait, do I still have it?
Am I still fast with it?
Or is it just poison?
Oh, I'm still fast with it.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
I need to figure out how to do this.
Okay, I do that, and then I go away.
up.
Then you get across that up.
And then up.
Okay.
Oh.
I don't think this is the run, but I'm just trying to I'm trying to figure this up.
I personally don't think this is the run.
Because I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm passing.
Yeah, I'm figuring out the speed where I'm passing right now.
Yeah.
Alright, now we're at Sinner's Road.
Oh, my God.
Oh, the dogs are awake now.
That's okay.
Pathfinding.
Okay.
Up.
Up left.
Okay.
Oh.
Aha!
Almost got me.
Almost got me there!
Okay, we gotta reset this.
I got scared.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god, that's close.
Alright.
path in here.
Okay.
I'm hesitating so much.
I'm so scared.
You guys have- I'm actually- I'm so scared.
I'm so fucking scared.
Okay.
No!
Oh, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I'll go left.
Oh, yeah, I should have just went left.
I don't know.
I got a little cheeky.
I got very cheeky.
Okay, I don't remember how to get out of here, though.
What do I do after here?
Was it...
Where am I?
Holy shit, okay.
The elevator.
Was it left?
Okay.
There we go.
That was close.
That was very close.
No, I fought that last judge.
I have to do the nail up.
Oh!
What are you doing?
Okay.
What the
hell?
No!
Guys, it's over.
It's...
It's over.
It's so over.
How do I...
Up.
Right.
It's so over.
Up.
Right.
Left.
Here.
Oh, is this?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, my God.
I keep thinking.
I was thinking about that.
Okay.
Up.
Left.
Here.
Okay.
Left.
Up.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
No.
Now it's over.
I hit the wall.
I accidentally hit the wall because I was trying to...
I was trying to figure out the path being.
I was trying to...
I was trying to figure out the path!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I got this.
I'm locking in.
I figured it out.
Well, I know the path thing to get to everywhere, but the citadel path.
But, like, that's good enough, right?
I went the wrong way already.
Alright.
Okay, up we go.
Oh, oh, nice.
Okay, elevator.
That's fine.
That scarecrow actually scared me.
Like, it's working.
I thought it was a real scarecrow.
I thought it was a real crow.
Every time.
What woke you up?
Okay, I gotta be gentle with this path.
Oh.
Now reset it.
I gotta reset it.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Please.
What have I done to you guys?
Okay.
So far.
So good.
Alright, two more hits.
Two more hits.
I jinxed myself with that.
That's on me.
That's also on me.
It's still possible.
Guys, it's so salvageable.
We can still fix this.
I figured it out.
I'm not risking that jump.
I just gotta have...
Imagine if the elevator hits me there.
Alright.
It's salvageable.
It's good practice.
It's for that plus three.
Oh my god.
Can't go too fast, guys.
Never go too fast
Okay There we go Oh my god Guys I don't know I don't know now I don't think we're gonna make it Oh my god I'm gonna sit down with my head again Okay What was the pathway again?
Okay left here Okay
Is it here?
No No
No That's...
It's too late.
This is hell.
This is actual hell.
How is I supposed to know he was above me?
Where was his blinker?
His blinker wasn't on.
Where's the cops?
Here we go again.
I figured out the path things for real now.
All right.
I almost went.
I almost took the quick, fast, fast.
All right.
Full concentration.
No yapp.
Oh my god.
I almost.
Thank god.
They got, they did a little jump.
I actually almost hit my head again.
Full focus.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I almost hit my head!
We're right there!
That was scary.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah.
Oh!
I need to like make sure I don't...
Aha!
Never mind!
Okay.
Jump here.
Okay, reset him.
He's reset.
No, no!
Oh, God.
I might have to reset these guys.
I messed it up.
That guy.
Alright.
It's fine.
We got the reset in.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, we're here.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We just jumped that.
All right.
We got here.
We're here.
Oh.
We're getting better.
I'm locking in.
We float down Because I'm scared
I'm very scared This is it This is it Oh, we still have it halfway And I don't know the path thing The worst part is that I don't know the path thing for this
We're looking good for now
Okay all right down okay then there's a wall here i remember the wall
all right all right okay this is the hard part this is this is the hard part all right left do i go up or do i just keep going left
Do I go up or keep going left?
Just keep going left?
Left all the way.
No!
Oh my god.
This is bad.
This is already bad.
Oh this is so bad.
I don't know.
I don't know about Pathic.
This was so bad.
Where do I go?
Wait.
How do I do this?
Wait, how do I do this?
How do I get up?
Oh my god.
No.
It's over.
It's so over.
It's already so over.
Oh my god, there was an inside.
It was an inside job this entire time.
time it's over it was inside the door it was an inside job
wait oh my god oh my god oh my god it's salvageable
My head is against the wall.
I can't.
This is the one time I use this.
I...
I hit my head against the wall.
You gotta collide.
I can't believe it.
It was the fucking door.
I was the door.
I was like, it's possible.
Yes, it's possible.
I can't...
I'll be dead for you sake.
The door.
It's the fucking...
It's the door.
It was the door.
Oh my god I was doing so well, dude.
That's the worst part I had zero hits until until I got to the Citadel because I got confused
It would have been so clutch I was like guys I'm doing it I'm doing and then I got doored
I felt so confident too.
The goddamn door!
Oh my god.
Door stuck.
I felt like, I felt so cool.
It's not up, not when you go in.
It's up, not right?
When you go into that room?
What do you mean?
Oops.
Oh my gosh.
I've already messed up this.
I don't know what that means.
It's right then up.
Oh, what does that mean?
Speak English!
Don't keep, we are speaking English, though.
Okay, all right
Okay Now we're here
All right, double jump this
All right Now we're back here
Oh, now we're back here hitting
the edge of the fucking hip-hop It's okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I don't know.
I found the edge.
I found the hitbox edge.
I just... this?
No.
That's just nothing.
Uh, confused.
Okay.
Here we go.
I actually thread that needle.
And then it ain't tricking me.
I know there's a step over there.
What?
My god.
Get me out of here.
What
is this RNG?
What is this RNG?
I don't remember.
Please.
my god went the wrong way oh my god it's over it's the spider threw me off at this time they didn't show they didn't show up they didn't show up last time where did they come from
I'm saying I didn't show up so I didn't expect it I didn't expect it
they weren't there it was such a good run I'm stuck
I'm progressing now I just wanted to live I just wanted a plus one one more nail upgrade Okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
I'm not okay.
But we're fine.
We're fine.
All right.
It's okay.
Okay.
I'm focused.
No, yeah.
I'm locking in.
I gotta deliver this.
I can't keep doing this quest.
The cat keep making me do this what?
Oh my god.
I got a little scared that that rat was gonna touch me.
Okay.
Alright.
Gotta reset this man.
I don't want him to chase me because I already have enough people chasing me.
Alright.
yeah oh made it here
I'm gaming I'm actually gaming right now oh shit I was I was actual pure ins no it's fine it's fine everything is fine everything is fine oh my god totally reflex It's just pure reflex now.
Toki, stop my eye!
Legitimately running on pure reflex right now.
Calm down, Toki, please.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't remember.
Okay, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck are the spike area again?
Oh my god.
Imagine if I hit my head on that area.
And then I walk.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You're not gonna play a cruel joke on me yet.
Okay, I need to remember how to get from here.
This is the...
Okay, it's on the other side.
Okay, here you are.
Okay.
Fuck right.
where's up where's the up
where's the up where's the up go back
oh my god oh my god please please please take the food please please take the my last my master is withering away from hunger let us see what gifts you bring oh is this the raster of a career tied up tight i could see it's fat silk dripping fresh we did it we fucking did it
so that abandoned chef recipes outlived them after all not so sir i claimed the maggot from the chef themselves their british work continued even with a shell claimed by cursed fred incredible a bug so devout they could cook with matic sponge the citadel was far too hasted expel such brilliance.
The nectar that's having such an age-ash extract still exists.
What a quizzle tragedy that cannot taste in myself.
My master must have every drop.
I bet you he's fucking dead, isn't he?
The stew of moss berries stir thick.
Good, good.
It shall form the base once set in mold.
A crescent still and all.
You'll be thinking, yes?
But brown tube finest pounder that's when its tart taste blooms with this i fulfilled a promise sir the ingredients have all been delivered i trust now the meal can be made and the oil awarded for my efforts you'll have your oil well firstly learn some patience the dish must be prepared perfectly enough to rouse my master and see them sated now permit me to work my And you'll stand to see the meal of scent and taste.
Now dazzle Farlum in her prime.
It's over.
I'm just so happy.
Taste, smell, texture.
It is done.
A meal to rival Farlum's finest.
Mighty Master, how long have you waited to set your jaw upon so perfect a dish?
Join us and die.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, yo, friendly.
What is that?
Yay, wish granted.
I did it.
Now I count my oil, right, sir?
Wineta.
Your master seems satisfied, sir.
time you gave what was promised.
Yes, yes, it has been done.
Made and served.
A dish to match my master's finest desires.
The pale truffle is yours.
Take care of leave.
My master needs time to reflect, and I must ponder on flavors on you.
Yay!
Goodbye.
See?
We're fine.
Alright, goodbye.
Why do I have to play it?
Oh
Sorry, my needle broke Oh my that had to be the most adrenaline fucking shit I ever done in a while That was I had so much adrenaline for this one fucking area All right, now I have to remember how to get home A dinner and a show.
After so, yeah.
Actual.
Oh my god.
Now I can upgrade my weapon.
I don't.
Grubhub delivery fee.
I did it.
I did the Grubhub.
Okay, this way.
No, I walked this way.
This is a victory lap.
We don't need a save and quit.
I'm doing my victory lap right now.
If I can remember where it is.
This is...
Oh, shit!
I was.
I'll get to walk back.
Ada!
Heya!
Take me back.
I did it.
No longer plus two.
It's plus three time.
I have my plus three needle.
I earned it.
Let me get rid of.
Wait, what was it before?
It was...
Oh, it's this.
There you go.
all right
that's fine have more oil pin master its acquisition was no small tax but if aids my blade those challenges will be well rewarded even more oil what preposterous luck the unseen gift and quantity unheard discovered by a single bud would you pass the oil traveler and perhaps a few rosaries for the ongoing effort allow this pin master to get and work wonder upon your blade 450
I didn't know.
I have relics.
Is that enough?
Please.
Take my money.
I smell something on you.
Head with a pasty right.
Yo, brother.
Yes.
Take my relics.
Yes, this is my collection.
Oh my god, not enough.
I need...
I need a hundred dollars more.
Do I have more?
No, I don't.
I'm just broke.
Okay, let me just put Umarang.
Um Oh my god, who cannot farm?
I think there was a bug over here.
Oh my god, I'm gonna beat this guy up.
He was like, hello.
I'll take your money.
Oh my god, it's just 12.
It's not worth it.
It's 12.
Yeah, I'm going back to the Citadel.
Yeah, I'll do the...
I know what you want to do.
As well as where I farm the money.
No, I can do...
No, this is...
This is faster.
I go here.
And I go...
I need this!
And then I got my money.
See?
It's so much faster.
Everything for plus three.
There's the stuff I...
I do.
We're plus three.
Oh my god, I don't have Adidas anymore.
My entire plan relied on Adidas.
It's fine.
It's so faster.
I do this.
Adidas!
Alright, nice.
How much is 430 or 450?
How much was it?
450?
All right, one more.
Adidas!
There you go.
All right, that should be enough.
Now I'm broke, broke.
Bellheart.
I hate that Bellheart.
I hate Bellheart so much.
It's like going to LA.
Fucking expensive as fuck.
All right.
I'm a constant state of broke.
Trapping my needle.
You do what you hoard.
You capitalist pig.
Do it.
Whoa.
He's like looping up my sword.
But this is a new cutscene.
Nice.
Well, he's done.
What miracle did it work?
again upon steel so fine few pins left and formerly contained such she you must tell me traveler whatever did you come upon such splendid weapon the blade was a gift gifted by a noble tribe of my homeland they forged the strongest so seal those are seen beyond their hive the tribe has now long passed with them the secret to their craft oh they're gone swear peace then will be guessed but what grand luck for this humble pin master that worked with such a a weapon all right oh is that the same cutscene i must have accidentally skipped the cutscene three times i think i actually skipped the cutscene three fucking times all right now we can progress the story let's actually do we do this i assume all of these are like boss fights so which one would be the closest i knew any of them i'll do this one This is the closest.
Oh, yeah, I'll do the one at the bottom.
This seems like the closest.
I'll go here.
Cogswork is the easiest one.
Which one's Cogswork?
Do they have names?
Oh, they do.
Guys, I'll fight Beastfly next stream.
Okay, I promise you.
Next stream, I'll fight Beastfly.
Architect's memory?
Okay.
Architect's memory.
Which one was the symbol for it?
It's this one.
Oh, okay.
So I should do that one then.
This is the easiest?
Is this the easiest?
Alright, I'll do that.
Alright.
I want to do a boss fight, though.
Is it not a boss fight?
fight?
Oh, none of them are?
Oh, oh, this one?
This is the boss fight?
Okay, we'll go to the right one then.
I'll do the boss fight then.
Wee!
There is a shortcut.
No, I will not talk to you.
a bad guy if you want to do it just head no that's fine that's okay we'll do it next stream guys this is fine we get guys we'll do it next stream guys i don't think i'm mentally prepared right now i can't not again oh god i have to be mentally prepared for a rematch i'm not emotionally ready for this
I hate these guys so much.
Oh, but they're so...
They died out faster, though.
Thank fucking God.
Actually, let's see what's over here.
I haven't explored here yet.
Oh, absolutely nothing.
That's cool.
Whoops, sorry.
Am I interrupting something?
It's okay.
Come on, guys.
Come back.
Come on.
Back here.
There we go.
That's right.
What you gotta do now?
He's dead.
That's right.
You're gonna hit me.
I mean, that works too.
What the fuck were they guard?
Oh, shortcut.
I see.
I was like, what are they guarding down there?
There's like nothing here.
What's this guy?
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
What are you here then?
What does this do?
What?
What is this for?
Huh?
Oh!
That's right, you can't hide money from me.
Wait, I'm still confused.
Haha, that's right.
Can't hide the money.
money from me.
Go up.
What did I do?
Secret top right.
Here?
That's what it was for.
I was like wondering what that thing was.
What did I do?
Wee!
Just hang out.
That's my bad.
That's actually my bad.
Oh my god.
What is over here?
Where am I?
Down I'll go.
Wee.
Oh!
Where did I go?
miss it!
Oh my god!
Where am I?
Where?
What is this hell?
Oh no.
This is poison swamps, isn't it?
Oh my god.
I'm actually at Poison Swamps.
I'm actually there I'm actually there
Where did I go?
Where am I?
I don't even know how to get back So either I don't I don't have one.
I ate them all.
They were just so good.
I ate all of my silk.
Alright, let's figure out how to get there again.
I don't remember.
I think it was like this way and then this way.
it?
No, it wasn't.
I've never even been here before.
No, I need a... I missed something though, didn't I?
What did I miss?
Didn't I miss something?
Yeah, I want to see if I can get back to where the fuck I missed.
Okay, so how do we do this?
Guys.
Okay.
Hug the left wall.
Wow, look at all these gears.
I didn't turn on.
Wait.
Alright.
Here we go.
We.
Here?
Alright.
God, really?
Oh my god Help, help, help I held
A I swear to God I swear to God I was holding A It's like not Like un-aided self It actually un-aided self Oh I was broke guys It doesn't matter I was so broke
Guys it didn't matter I remember when I used all my money Where What do you mean?
I was broke.
I remember I had nothing.
Oh yeah, I never realized there was this over there.
Jokes on them.
I spent it all.
This is it.
Oh wait, this is not it.
Oh my god, this is it.
It's fine.
We don't need that bench to here.
Don't touch that wall.
So I'm gonna freaking freak out.
Yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I mean, there's nothing I could do.
There's nothing I could do.
Alright, here we go again.
Where's my cocoon?!
Where is it?!
Where is it?
Oh my god, it went down!
Oh hey, there it is!
What did I do?
Oh.
Okay.
Where am I?
Now where am I?
What is this place?
why why is this world so cruel why come
in here that's fucking right come in here this is my domain please stop right all right I'll grab him all
right where are you
Are you kidding me?
Alright.
Wake up!
Ooh!
Alright, nice.
He woke up.
What is he doing here?
Oh my god, I didn't mean to do that.
Is there anything else here?
That I should get?
Or am I done?
Is there anything up?
Okay, nothing up there?
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't need that money.
I don't need it.
Job done.
Wait, I'm back here.
Wait, I thought you guys said there was a mask.
What the fuck was that for?
Do you know a mask there?
A fleet.
Oh my god.
bottom let oh my god I want here I did all of that because I thought you guys said there was a mask I you guys just wanted the awu it was just for awu okay we go down I
should need I need silk right now Oh, shit.
That's fine.
Got the silk.
Okay, down we go.
Give me your silk!
How do I get down?
Wait, how do I get down?
Guys, I can't get down.
I just realized.
Oh, from this room?
Oh!
Okay, I see it
Yeah This way.
Oh my god forgot about you your stupid spot-ass
Oh my god, no not again Not again.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
Like where am I?
This area I hate this area so much but not again it's fine it's just a speedrun tech I'm just oh my god I'm trying to remember how to get back it's fine land this way I have no money it's okay I lose nothing when
I lose nothing.
What can I lose when I have nothing?
Truly is such a sad moment.
Exactly.
Nothing of value was lost.
I missed a shortcut.
That's fine.
We don't need shortcuts.
Life is not about shortcuts, guys.
Sometimes, you gotta not take shortcuts to live life.
Grab that.
Oh wait, I remember this area.
Alright, let's just go down.
I don't remember that area.
That's over here.
Oh, it's another of these.
Oh, come on.
I didn't see it Because it's so dark
Are you serious?
Shit
Oh my god I lost track I lost track What was after that?
What was after that?
Is this?
I forgot I forgot Is this or that?
And then what was it?
One or...
One, two.
Left?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God we did it.
Okay.
I did it.
Guys.
Nice.
I got fucking Cogheart fees.
There we go.
There I go.
How do we open that pathway?
Wait, I should have to do this.
Oh, great lad who's flamed, doth falter, who's quiet, conducted, all doth fall.
Observe, take heart.
That spark's still burning.
You'll be on butterfly of crimson grace.
A bell shall peel and voices raised When brave Trobio steps at last Upon the sage Alright Please tell me there's a bench Please tell me there's a bench Somewhere
Hello Hello Grab some of these Oh every man
Oh wait I remember this Oh, thanks, guys.
Thank God.
Alright, let me check my items real quick.
See if I have everything I want to equip.
Alright.
That's fine.
This run back is not that bad.
Oh my god.
Okay, fine.
I won't use you as a platform.
Alright.
Oh, I could have...
Oh, you're right.
I could have equipped the dice.
Yeah, I'm going to...
Okay.
I'm going to equip the dice.
Let me farm these guys for silk, too.
Alright.
There we go.
I need a silk anyway.
I'm going to equip my dice.
Because I don't need this anymore.
What else do I want to do?
Oh, yeah.
I'll use the parry.
Parry might be good.
Alright.
I have silky now.
So it can't be that bad.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'm ready Hello Oh Drab trembling squib You who timidly stepped on to the great sage Fate has seen you chosen Cast away your fear And join me as my partner Barlooms flame may flicker But together we shall spark it ablaze Let us enliven the still Lost in silence Let us rouse the soul This one Great land.
Introducing Corporate Trovia!
Chaser!
Oh my god.
What the fuck am I?
What?
What is this?
Chaser.
I hate this.
I actually hate this.
Oh my god!
I don't know what to do.
I...
Okay.
Might hate this boss.
I think...
I think I hate this boss, guys.
I...
Remember when I tell you?
My biggest weakness is random bullshit?
Yeah!
Oh my god, did they?
I hate this.
I actually hate this.
Jesus Christ, look at it.
Trubio!
Ha ha!
Oh my god.
Trubio!
Oh my god, he actually destroys my chainsaw.
What a fucking freak.
Oh my god, of course, that hits me.
Trovio!
Stupid Trovio.
Oh my god, he keeps breaking my chainsaw.
Oh my god.
Chainsaw does not do well against Trovio.
Ooh, what I thought.
Are you serious?
Stupid Trobio.
Stupid Trobio!
Oh my god, I actually got scared.
Huh?
Oh my god, stupid random bullshit.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Chainsaw does nothing.
against Trobio.
Trobio does not see weapons.
Yeah.
I want to grab some fucking scraps real quick.
I don't have shards.
I might have to fight this boss with no tools.
Except for my...
My flea flea juice.
Whoops.
Oh hey, didn't do anything.
All right, that was an accident.
Oh, wait.
I think I should use the Perry.
Ah, does Perry work against his twirls, guys?
Does Perry work against the...
Yeah?
Okay.
All right, Perry.
I hate you, Trubio.
Trubio, I fucking hate you so much.
I hate you.
Oh, my.
I've got Trubio!
Stop!
I hate him.
Okay.
I'm not using anything.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I can hate hit the bombs.
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright.
I'm locking in then.
No wonder they cancelled your show.
Trobeo.
No wonder they locked you up and cancelled it.
I thought it hit.
Oh, Mac.
I hate you.
I actually hate you so much.
Trobeo.
I don't
know.
That's fine.
There you go.
Oh my god, fucking course.
A fucking course, you whore.
Stupid tornado ass.
Troobio!
Alright, night.
I will say that was a nice dodge.
Stupid Troobio.
There you go.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, that was an accident.
fast.
I was so fast.
I Oh my god, I was not used to speed.
Okay, I'm not using the lead juice, guys.
I was too fast.
The speed actually fucked me up.
The speed actually fucked me up there.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
No excuse explosions for me.
Ah, he jumped in!
Oh!
What's the flint?
I don't even know what the flint is.
Alright.
Flint.
I don't think...
Oh my god, I got stomped so high.
What do you mean by flint?
Oh, I don't have it.
Oh, you mean the...
The one that everyone kept telling me.
Yeah, it's like, no!
I will get it.
Maybe I should have got...
Okay.
Yeah, I need the compass, guys.
You don't understand.
It's important.
Trubio!
That boomerang.
Get boomerang!
That's right!
Trubio!
I didn't think that would hit me.
Not gonna lie.
Friends.
Just gotta be sure.
I'm very focused right now.
Oh my god, there's so many balls.
There's a lot of balls in my face right now.
okay nice oh
he's so lucky
that's right get predicted that's right
okay that's fine
trubio oh my god wait that's phase two that's phase two of trubio tab
twin Please stop tornadoing Oh my god, I said stop I said stop
Oh my god, that was not good for me I got hit by the random bullshit
Okay There you go
I'm like, I'm gonna not, I'm not using my abilities for this.
I need the heal.
Heal is so much more important right now.
I, fuck.
Oh, my God.
Trubio.
No.
Not
the tornado.
The stupid Trubio.
I was I was feeling that run too
Oh my god, that was a good attempt Okay,
yeah, they're yeah, no this is not the run That was not the run Oh my god, that was a waste
that was so bullshit though what he did oh I dashed into that oopsie I would like to call oopsie oopsie daisy
okay that's true you I wish I'm so happy to cancel your stupid show okay
That's right.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Troobio!
Oh my god.
He's trooping out.
I- ow!
I don't- Okay.
That's fine.
That was so many.
That's so many bullshit!
There was so much random bullshit.
That's fine.
Okay.
Yeah, we did it!
Get Trubioed!
Oh, shit!
God fucking got Trubioed!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Trubioed.
That's right.
Get Trubioed.
Fuck you and your random bullshit.
bullshit I got claw mirror what the fuck is that When binding emits it all Bravo Let me see what was it emissio bravo What go back leave and come back Oh
Yeah, yeah?
Yeah?
You ain't gonna be 10?
Stupid Trubio.
Such a dedicated actor.
So dramatic.
Wait, what does it look like?
Oh!
He's so dramatic, silly Trubio.
Oh, that's a shortcut.
He's so committed.
Where does
this go?
I'm so scared.
Like, I keep going down, I'm like scared.
Oh, I broke that.
What now?
Wait, what?
Guys, what about this?
Guys.
So that was optional, wasn't it?
Did you make me do an optional boss fight?
That...
Guys.
I said...
I don't...
Well, I don't think he's optional.
Guys.
The troveo is...
No, you don't understand.
He is...
optional.
Yeah, he is a mandatory.
I... Oh.
Troobio!
Takedo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
He's not optional to me, Toki!
He is a mandatory How do I go under the elevator?
He's not a option.
My Artuki!
Tropio!
I didn't go under that elevator?
How the fuck do I go under that elevator?
Oh, send it down.
Ops.
Ow.
It is mandatory in our heart.
The real thing.
Even the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Then send it up.
How do I send it up?
Oh, I just climb it up.
Oh!
Go up.
I didn't see the lever, guys.
There we go.
My eyes, they don't see.
I don't see levers.
There she has bugs.
Alright.
Trobio.
Trobio would have seen the loud- well, Trobio's dead!
His- his acting career, that is.
His acting career is dead.
He might as well be dead.
You take that back, Tokey.
Oh.
Yeah, critics say his acting may or may not be mediocre.
You put respect to his name.
It's Trubio!
All right, there's this stuff.
Nice view.
I'm dealing a melody upon the cylinder.
I'll first need to find a working device to play it.
This one here has long ceased to function.
surely hold another such device I must search for Oli right now where am I I'm so sad oh my he comes after me I don't trust myself so I have to yeah oh
my god He's still coming after me.
Holy shit, where am I?
Oh my god, there's more
Oh bench to the right really?
All right, I'll go back
I'm scared, but I will go back He scares me
I'm not gonna like dash all oh there it is.
Oh, thank god there is up end I will unlock this area first.
Oh my god, I don't know, I thought I was faster.
Apparently not.
Apparently I was not faster.
Oh, I thought I could kill him too.
I thought a lot of things.
Where am I now?
Oh, I'm here.
Oh, I unlocked it.
Is everything unlocked now?
Alright.
Yeah, I've been everywhere here.
Alright, wait.
Oh, that's the guns.
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Alright, we're gonna sit on that bench.
Again.
Alright, we got a boss.
I'm calling it here.
We got a bench.
We're good.
Alright.
I hope you guys...
enjoyed today's stream.
That was a fun day.
It was a fun.
It was a, this is our, another filler episode.
It was our prison break.
I did a boss.
It's Trobio.
What?
Was Trobio not enough for you guys?
What happened?
I thought Trobio was not optional in your hearts.
What?
We had another, we were at our prison break arc, but then we broke out of prison and then we had an art fill art within the prison break arc where we went back to prison um pros trivia cons trivia died we made a lot and we got plus three now guys we broke it we broke the curse we went beyond we can count we can count beyond too oh my god guys to have like three confirmed we count we count it to three guys anyway next stream we will do i'll do savage beast fly guys next stream i promise i will fight i will rematch him next stream anyway guys as always everybody we had a great time watching i'm gonna relax now oh i was finally doing it like a four hour stream but i was extra lost in that prison i was so lost hey guys i'm gonna head off now as always everybody Stay hydrated,
posture check.
Get up, move around, get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Trobio out.
Yee!